Either way,
I could,
depending upon the day,
I could argue both ways.
Greg,
mother and fog can improves his
hay on the Joe Rogan experience.
All say,
Greg Proops is one of those
dudes that actually wrote a book.
I'm one of those dudes who threatens
to write a book but never does it.
But you're one of those dudes
who actually wrote a book,
the smartest book in the world.
You bad motherfucker.
You,
I just learned to read.
And so I thought why not put it to use?
I have another level of respect
for people who write books.
Uh,
it took so long Joe w e now you
think it's going to be easy,
you think you'd get a skin to,
cause it's,
you know,
off the podcast,
right?
I obviously had its cheap,
you know,
marketing ploy from the
smartest man in the world,
your podcasts.
Because when they said what
would you call the book?
And when I went into the meeting,
I was like the smartest book in
the world and they were like,
love it,
you know?
So that was a couple of years ago.
And,
uh,
it took about a year and a
half to kind of get together.
I thought I'd be able to take like
transcripts from the shell and then I
realized they don't read that well,
you know,
there's too much doubling doc.
There's too much internal logic and
this is a big difference between oral
reading and writing.
They goddamn difference.
And sometimes like for standup comedy,
that's like why one of the most
important things is you have to do both.
And the guys who only do one or the other,
it's easily,
it doesn't,
it doesn't.
I mean some guys can pull it off.
Some guys,
some guys just like to just go
up and just keep going up all,
all the time and just going over the
material in their head like Sorta of Jay z
style and never actually sitting
down and writing things out.
I know guys who don't,
you know,
only a key word here and there.
And then I was just in Denver and I made
everybody get their book out cause I
wanted to look at everybody's book.
You know,
like I had an obsessed with the fact that
we're the last people who write things
on pieces of paper all the
time for our own information.
Like the rest of the world
has completely gone phone.
Really?
I think so.
But I mean,
I dunno,
EEG you carry a little,
you carry up notebook,
right?
I carry a notebook when I perform me tell
you a little one of those little tiny
mole skins.
And so you're but like,
so I took mine out and of course it's
just a sheaf of garbage with like every
napkin and stationary from every hotel
and earth and the stuffed into mole
skins.
And then the other guy takes his out,
Deacon Grace's,
his name is Jennifer comic and
his is written like a playwright.
Each page,
it's just beautifully,
every word of the joke written down.
And I'm like,
I write like corn,
you know,
and then try to remember the other
18 minutes that goes with it.
And so like you say,
sometimes you need to write the
whole thing out and look at it.
But my question was,
and I don't know if this works with you,
if you write something down
on a piece of paper for me,
I remember it.
If I type it into something,
yeah,
that's,
they're going to read it a thousand times.
They've done studies on that actually,
that the best way for someone to remember
something is actually physically write
it.
Longhand rush.
I don't,
it's cursive longhand.
Is that what they called [inaudible]?
They call that long,
but I mean just writing.
I don't write in cursive.
I don't know anyone who writes in cursive.
Not when my mom does and she sent
me a whole letter the other in ice.
I couldn't read it halfway through.
I just gave up because I
don't even the z our thing,
I can't tell what seasons ours.
Yeah.
What's wrong with the
microphone and that was it.
Flopped on spinning wants
to microphone as limp.
Michael Michael Moore wrote this thing
about running for president a couple of
weeks ago.
That was pretty funny.
He's not doing it,
but one of the things he said was,
well,
the first thing he said was
universal courts for everything.
Right?
For all devices,
all computers,
phones.
He goes,
we've had the same plug in
the wall for a hundred years.
There's not 16 different ones.
Why is every device,
well,
almost everybody,
but apple uses a micro SD USB,
right?
Every brand they change.
But he also said,
uh,
um,
everyone has to be taught cursive.
And his reason was it's the one
thing that's absolutely distinct,
like a fingerprint.
Every human we are signature is,
you know what I mean?
You can copy people's signatures,
but we all learn our own way
to write old government tricks.
Yup.
And so I agreed with him on that.
I thought,
I don't really write letters and cursive
like your mother did because she went
to school before,
but I learned cursive.
Oh my God.
When I was eight years
old or nine years old,
you know.
Well,
the way right is always like,
it's always distinctive.
So much so it's a,
it's a segment in television
shows and movies and plots.
You know,
they bring in the hand
writing analysis guy,
giant loop on the P and a giant loop
on the g means extending personality.
And the devil o's or you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
It can break you down.
And how you,
do you have the same signature that
you did when you started comedy?
Uh,
yeah.
Did you abbreviate it?
Ish?
You know,
I,
I do.
I have an abbreviated one in case
I got assigned a thousand things.
And where there's two versions.
Not a lot of letters.
Yeah.
Well it's just kind of gs and P's.
I liked the people who've narrowed
their signature down to like nothing.
It just looks like a blob.
And you're like,
that doesn't look like your name.
That's kind of a
Willie Mays.
I have a couple of autograph setup.
I didn't get them personally,
but they were given to me and Willie
Mays learn handwriting in the dirties in
Alabama where he grew up,
I'm sure in his little school.
Right.
So his writing goes
the other way entirely.
Like it doesn't look like Willie Mays.
It looks like we,
we mean like all going one way.
And I looked at it for
ages until I figured out,
oh,
he's holding it like this and glean
that with his w because making a w
completely backwards to the
way you'd make a w and a,
but babe Ruth who went to school in the,
uh,
early turn of the century in Baltimore,
and he went to an industrial school where
the priests and the nuns beat you and
stuff,
you know,
like old school.
Yeah.
He went to one of those,
his signature is absolutely beautiful and
he wrote with his left hand and if you
wrote lefthanded then it was terrible
because you were using a fountain pen and
he dipped it in a well,
so your hand goes across your work.
Yes.
Cory lefthander had to learn
to write with their hand up.
Yeah.
Writing left handed is a real bitch then.
That's a real bitch.
I,
I tried to practice it
once when I broke my arm,
I couldn't write with my right hand.
So I started like writing
things with my left and I was,
it was bizarre.
First of all,
it's bizarre how shitty
your left hand works.
Yes.
It's incredibly amazing how poor.
Yeah.
I mean if you think about what your
right hand can do with drawing things and
writing things down very quickly with
excellent control of your fingers,
excellent articulation and you switch
over to your left hand like you get tired
writing.
It's such an effort.
You have to concentrate all of
your right brain on writing.
My right arm now is starting to turn
into my left arm just from using cell
phones too much.
How I set and use my computer.
You guys getting early signs
of carpal tunnel or something,
but it's turning week.
I could feel it get weaker.
Your right hand,
my right arm.
You've over used it with
the devices so much.
Well they say that when people with thumbs
that thumbs now they have more carpal
tunnel issues with thumbs and like
ever in human history between x boxes,
gameboys and texting and things.
This now it's all this one movement and
with kids there's some kids that are
fucking it.
Dick did.
You know like we've all,
we've,
we've had many conversations
on this podcast about
electronic addictions and how
real they are now.
Like Ari Shaffir just switched over to um,
uh,
a little,
a flip phone and somebody
else just flipped out,
switched over to a flip phone too.
Oh,
Rory Macdonald,
UFC fighter.
He switched over to,
he's like on a smart phone.
Yeah.
He's like,
it's just too much.
I just,
I just don't feel like
I get enough me time.
I'm just constantly dealing with texts
and tweets and looking at this video and
watching that,
that,
do you think that Chad trauma,
that's why they're going
back to the flip phone?
Both Ari and Rory.
Rory.
Rory has been hit,
but rarely.
He's very skillful.
Already lost his other phone.
I made a conscious decision and talked
about it while he had his iPhone.
How dare you?
I really,
well he really did man.
All right.
It's good though.
I know people who use old and ones I got,
I got a buddy in Illinois
and he brought out his,
and he had a little
razor man and I was like,
why not?
I don't think you have
to do everything every,
I got buddies too who are on Twitter that
are comedians and they just want their
privacy.
They're not on Facebook.
They want to live their lives.
And I I say right on because I find
myself wasting too much time on it.
You know what I mean?
Is the difference between
doing your business on it?
Cause we all got a tweet and do all that,
you know,
and go on periscope and shoot
each other and be the monkeys.
But you,
when you find yourself
just going through Twitter,
just looking for something
that's interesting,
you're like,
yeah,
I could be,
you know,
building a home out of bricks or getting
something actually done writing a
Sonnet to my wife or something.
You're reading a book?
Yeah,
like my smartest book in the world.
Like why would you fuck with Twitter
where you can just read that?
I don't think I Bang Bang on
the Internet too much in there.
I little bit.
There's a few things because the
dull www worldwide web thing.
I'm like,
worldwide web is three syllables and www.
It's nine syllables.
So why do we say the
abbreviation that's so
much faster to say that we'll
be able to web is way quicker.
That's hilarious.
I never thought of that until right now.
And I put it in the book like,
why have we said www for ions?
So fucking funny.
Did you find Willie Mays?
Isn't it?
Isn't it though like you and
no one ever said anything?
And like someone pointed it
out to me a couple years ago,
a friend went like,
um,
why do we say this?
And I'm like,
oh my God,
w w w worldwide.
Because we think are
shortening that by saying,
tell you know,
like,
Hey,
that's a hip way to say it.
Stuttering.
Then why don't we just
say dub dub or something?
Some connection to life.
There's something in that.
There's a reason why life is so goofy.
That's,
that's gotta.
There's gotta be some connection.
I stick that one in there.
And uh,
and Steffi,
I like words that I hate and stuff.
There's a couple chapters on that.
Then just words.
Well like,
you know,
people I said like soups
and Cray cray and all that.
That'll,
I said in 50 years it'll be like saying
buggy whip or whipper snapper or you
know,
people use cray cray in anonymous
or in an ironic rather way.
I don't mind that.
If something fucks up and some
guy does something really stupid,
someone goes to him,
he,
Craig Craig,
you know,
that's fun.
Yeah.
If they don't really mean it.
But if they do mean,
it's like,
Ooh,
you just shouldn't accept that
level of culture automatically.
I agree.
Yeah.
It used to be some bulwark
against the barbarians.
There has to be something against the
horde of sheep or willing to all act and
behave the same.
Yeah.
There's gotta be something.
There's got to be,
not having a smartphone is one way.
I remember Jen was a John Waters who
didn't have the email up til like a couple
of years ago.
I was he there?
He,
he would have someone take down everything
in hand in the Sheaf of paper and
he'd like go through all
the messages and everything.
That's hilarious.
I thought that was,
yeah.
I would like to say you remember
when people used to use it?
Like if you had,
you know,
at Red Bam,
it would be is going to the doctor today.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like it wasn't a,
it wasn't a direct,
it was sort of you were talking
about yourself in the third person.
That was the way people
initially use Twitter.
I,
you know,
and I was on,
I was like,
get the fuck out of here.
I'm not going to do that.
I'm just going to just talk normal.
But there was a lot of people that
used it like at your name and then a,
you know,
is having a great time at the movies.
Like who you are.
You haven't,
you can't say I'm riding
in the conditional,
you see I'm a third party observer
to my own life at all times.
I'm narrating myself.
Greg is having a good time being here
on the Joe Rogan show at this moment and
you get fucked if you have
too many letters in your,
in your little name.
Right.
Because if you have the
real Greg Proops Esquire,
right,
then we'll then,
your tweets are going to be really short.
No,
hardly adventurous rabbi.
Yeah.
I mean your tweets can
be still 140 characters,
but no one's gonna
retweet the whole thing.
And I've never going to quote tweet
it because they can't now cause you,
you're fucking name's too long.
God dammit.
Wow.
These people trying to issue I have with
all of these things is they're all fun
and they're all great
and they're all grieving.
And the reason why I have a
careerist cause there's an internet,
but uh,
Eh,
I just find that everybody
trusts technology too much
in so much as the people
who make it.
And then people who are over watching us,
uh,
they are not benign.
Well,
it was this some dark overlord type shit.
We're not going to go to the room full
of 11 men and the council of five or
nothing like that.
I'm just saying,
you know,
be mindful of all the stuff he tape.
You know,
people,
people just tape every intimate moment
of their lives and all of a sudden,
just like in the movie with Cameron Diaz,
you're on the cloud and it's getting
worse and worse for me because I've been
staying at home a lot more trying to
and so have like webcams where they're
recording me,
played video games and stuff and
I'll forget that I have that on.
And then next thing you know,
like,
uh,
like a day later I'm sitting
there talking and I realized that,
oh,
I'm just talking like Jamie could just
be sitting there and listening to me
right now.
And uh,
because it's so easy to do with like
Xbox live or all these other things.
Yeah.
That's a new thing and it's going to
transition probably into something even
more invasive.
It's probably going to be like,
look,
we're saying before like some
sort of a Google glass thing.
We're like through a ski
helmet type situation where,
you know,
that's what they're working
on with that magic leap.
Right.
Wasn't that part of it
was either magically,
but one of the other ones that
they're working on where they,
they can spin objects in the air in
front of them and stop them and move them
and stretch them out.
Like you could open like minority report,
right?
You're doing it in the air
minority report was on like a,
was it a screen?
Yeah,
no screens.
You're just doing it in the air.
The world becomes your desktop.
And I think we're talking about
two different technologies.
I think that um,
the other stuff is,
um,
the magic leap thing.
I think it's a different type.
Yeah.
Well there's that Sony,
uh,
this one,
oh,
this is the watch that's on your arm.
It's a windmill,
a group of benign people
who care about you,
who are well groomed,
are thinking right now about your future.
Advertise that.
So cool.
Anytime you have an advertisement for
anything that might even be potentially
remotely dangerous,
those advertisements
should all be illegal.
I've been watching advertising slaves,
well,
excuse me,
lately,
lately on like a late night television,
they have all these
advertisements about drugs.
Like,
ask your doctor all these,
ask your doctor commercials.
And I'm like,
these commercials are terrifying.
And then they,
when did they start listing the side
effects and sometimes side effects,
death or suicide,
you know like really dude,
this side effect from
this one thing for Zits,
the entire,
I don't know what the medication is,
but it was a genuinely disturbing
video because you know that happy song
they,
they're only playing like
the background music.
They don't have the law,
the lyrics and the music
then of the vocals.
But these two girls are walking
and Bob up and down the street,
like they're in a fucking
music video and it's
about zits and it's about your
zits are keeping you from being,
so you've got to ask your doctor about
this medication that stops your zits.
And then he goes through
all the lists of shit.
You should be careful of colluding,
bloody diarrhea.
Oh my goodness is in
the fucking commercial.
And they're,
they're saying you have to be careful
of abdominal crank cramps because they
could be fatal.
You got to go to your doctor
if any of these things happen.
And I mean,
they've run through all fucking laundry
list of shit that you have to be worried
about.
Where I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
This is real and this is on TV.
And then they allowed them in
your girls taking a narrow,
they manipulate you with the
dancing and the pretty girls.
This is the shit.
We're not showing this
to the rest of the world,
right?
What's it called?
Oh,
next dawn.
Okay,
so it's got these girls,
they're beautiful.
They're fucking flawless.
They don't have a mark on their face.
How come you can't get someone
with zits that needs this shit?
You've got these gorgeous model girls and
while they're jogging down the street,
this fucking happy song is playing.
Do is dark.
It's dark because dead eyes.
Yeah,
I was gonna say.
And then an alien comes aboard
and takes control of your life,
but they're showing you the ideal.
This is the idea that
Wallace people after.
Yeah,
but think about what they're selling.
Well,
who the fuck looks like this?
If I,
if I take this medication
while I looked like that girl,
like why do you have that girl?
Why is she so beautiful
that she has zip problems?
So why are you using her for this
fucking commercial either that's like,
you know,
showing Lexington steel in a big penis,
cream commercial,
no show.
Show a regular dude with a little deck.
Grow a big deck.
Okay,
you can't,
you can't show giant dicks.
Like I was born with a giant Dick
and it's the same thing here.
Those girls were born flawless.
I mean that girl has a
perfect skin structure or a
bone structure and beautiful
clear skin and she's dressed fashionably
and the music is playing great and her
hair's blowing just so in the wind where
it looks like a casual summer day and
you're like,
God,
if I just took this medication,
I can hang with these bitches.
No,
you don't look at it as he liked him.
It's insane.
Everywhere they go,
there's models.
It's like the world.
The world's filled with tens and you're
going down the street bopping to music
and everyone's got a little dog.
Like,
what the fuck are you selling?
Oh,
and the beautiful backdrop that they
were in front of that lovely building and
then there was woods and whatnot.
There was no rappers anywhere.
Homeless people are,
no,
there's no,
it's a fantasy.
Yeah,
no.
Which is what?
She lost a foot to diabetes pushed around
in a wheelchair asking you for money.
What's the expression?
Impossible beauty standards.
Say this is a,
this coal commercials one it long
impossible beauty standard and it's about
something that's,
you know that fucks with people and
you get zits all over your face.
Scary face is a crazy side effects may
include dre come an alien with Brac made
here the side effects.
See Jamie,
see if you can find out what the
side effects are because they,
we've got to play it because
they'd go on for like a minute.
I mean the side effects
just fucking keep going.
Getting your attention.
Especially if fused with
other acne products.
Stop using,
call your doctor if you have
a rash or very red burning,
itchy or swollen skin.
Limit your time in the sun.
Avoid tanning beds.
And suddenly it says stop hiding.
That's not the whole one.
You got to go before that where it says
you could die your time in the sun.
Stop use if you develop severe watery or
bloody diarrhea or severe as these may
be fatal.
Okay,
let's just stop right there
and back that up one more time.
Well,
I want to hear that one more time.
Stop.
Use If you develop severe watery or
bloody diarrhea or severe abdominal cramps
as these may be fatal police,
be fatal in the actual fuck tonight.
Not to overuse a term like cray cray,
but
seriously what in the actual fuck.
Like you,
I was watching that commercial last
night on TV during a hunting show.
Okay.
I'm watching a show about hunting.
Wow.
And they have this commercial
about bloody diarrhea.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
I might've just changed channels.
I might be wrong about
what I was watching on,
but it wasn't wrong about the,
the actual commercial
itself being insanity.
No,
and the visuals and the sound track
don't match at that moment and they're
talking about bloody diarrhea.
She casts a side long glance and throws
her head often gets ready to run.
I don't think we should be so flippant.
I know influence of these
goddamn commercials at all.
I think this is like,
this is like coercion.
It's like Voodoo.
They're doing like they're
brainwashing people.
What's the actual number?
Somewhere in the neighborhood
of with the phone now,
it used to be hundreds of ads a
day just walking around and TV,
but with the phone I
think it's up to what,
three,
5,000 a day or something like that.
The abs that you have to,
there's a link your way doing ads,
man,
and it's all blind bids and Dang and
poisoning and it has an agenda and the
agenda is to take money
from you and fool you.
Well,
I don't worry about that
when it comes to like cars,
as long as the cars are safe,
like make it sex age,
Judge Viper,
I don't mind that you're going to convert,
coerce me in that way.
That's fine.
I do mind that though of I
might get bloody diarrhea.
That kills me.
You're coercing me.
Imagine if you're a young girl,
well you might have an unfortunate
looking face and you just always felt like
you're an outcast.
And maybe if my skin was clear,
then I wouldn't be
scared to go to the gym.
You know,
maybe those girls at school would be
nicer to me and I'd have more popular
friends.
And you see this fucking commercial and
the next thing you know you're going to
your doctor and the next thing you know
after that you got bloody diarrhea and
you're dying.
How would you get bloody diarrhea though?
Cause it wouldn't be the only one way,
but it wouldn't be bright,
right?
It'd be like that black,
red diarrhea,
turnip,
dire situation,
an acne medicine.
It's giving you a journal.
Da approved this,
but knew that within a certain group,
however,
what a number is,
whatever they feel the number of safe
that many people out of that number,
it's okay that they get these things
as long as you say consult with your
doctor,
that,
uh,
probably adheres to some
code within the God.
That's one of the situation.
And I'll not jive really.
One of the more fascinating things about
us biologically is the fact that you
could take something and it
has no effect on you at all.
And I can take the same
thing and die like,
you know,
things that people are severely
allergic to or allergic reactions,
even to medication.
I mean,
how many times do you ever been asked
if you're allergic to penicillin?
Imagine being the poor bastard
that's allergic to penicillin.
Fuck man.
I could go be,
you know,
uh,
one person,
nothing.
Net guy next to him.
He'll die.
I'm allergic to penicillin.
Do you have to wear a little
virgin?
Being allergic to penicillin is a,
you're allergic to all the ceilings.
The mock is still in the stone,
I said.
And those are in other institutions?
Yeah,
so and I get strep throat a lot
and like almost once a year.
And so that normally you'd
just take penicillin.
I had no idea you were allergic to that.
That's wild.
And some with something
that's not as effective.
How did you find out?
Did you take penicillin
or did they test you?
Yeah.
As a kid I took it and I broke up in
this huge rash and stuff like that.
And then could you agree?
Could you breathe when you
had that was fine breathing,
but it was all over me.
So it was pretty gross.
But it was obvious it happened
within a certain oh yeah.
And it happened immediately.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So,
but you realize,
eh,
that before penicillin,
the casualties in wars and
stuff were off the charts.
Like what does it world war one is
when it gets invented because yeah,
the lack of good antibiotics to treat
any kind of post a wound infection or any
kind of what terrifies me is how nature
is trying to keep up with antibiotics.
And they have these Murcia infections
that people get where they are.
They're hospitalized for months.
I mean,
some people late catch Marissa,
they get what mercy is like
medication resistant staph,
something another.
I think that's what it stands for.
But,
uh,
it's,
it's particularly,
um,
particularly,
uh,
common in surgery cases for some reason.
Like,
people have surgery.
What happened?
Nothing.
I just caught a look at myself on camera.
That Gilead Cronenberg water buffalo hair.
Someone sitting in the,
what is it?
Periscope chat.
The of genius here.
That's what I'm going for.
A mad genius.
Genius.
Here it goes with your purview.
Professor Myalgia posted.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
We were just talking about a Merva.
They're being resistant to antibiotics.
Murcia that scares the shit out of me
that they're trying to get stronger as we
make more.
I mean,
it's almost like there's a
war go like any bacteria.
That's about it.
Yeah.
The,
the,
eventually those won't work well.
Do you know some people
that use them all the time?
They get so crazy that they get the kill
all the resistance in their hands to
other bacteria so they get warts
and shit all over their hands.
It's like really common for people to
become addicted to that stuff that Amy is
not a bad idea.
Every now and again to give yourself a
little Antivia bacterial on the hands,
stuff that Jay Gelb,
it smells like the alcohol.
It's gotta be good for you.
It's,
I like medicine,
but some,
my friend went over to looked at a house
and inside of the house was a closet
full of the stuff.
What?
Yeah,
they were going to buy this house.
They went and looked in the house and
they opened this door and there was a
fucking closet fill
with one hand sanitizer.
Just bottles and bottles
and bottles and bottles.
Like a crazy person was terrified
of running out of hand sanitizer.
It's been a godsend for Germaphobes.
Yeah.
Everyone is an anal drove a
bluffs that cause they just,
their average two seconds.
I'm know some people and they're always,
you know,
like that's a psychological thing,
right?
It's like odd or what did they call it?
OCD.
Not Ocd.
So don't you think that
that almost like fuels it?
Like having,
that's what I mean,
it's,
it's absolutely being validated that
the thing you're afraid of is true.
You know,
I'm afraid of touching
anything or touch anything.
Like I,
when I do my podcast,
I talked to everyone in the audience
before the show for a while and I shake
everybody's hand.
So I'm communicating whatever disease
anyone's giving me to everyone and I don't
use hand sanitizer.
I'll go in the restroom and wash my
hands after that and then start the show.
But we all have to take that chance.
We're all humans and live with each other
and it's good for your immune system
tied to lie.
I've never gotten sick from
it and I'm never nothing bad.
Don't go look in your hands though.
Like I say,
I'll wash my hands after the shell.
I did not.
I did not,
uh,
pleasure myself or dance around her.
Make a Taco or it.
And how is it that this is a concern?
Just think about the actual
existence of human beings.
How bizarre is it that there's a concern
that you might get an organism that's
attached to another person?
That organism will threaten the very
ecosystem that your life depends on.
That's real.
Like that's how people get colds.
You,
you're rubbing up against an organism.
You get it in your body because it came
off of someone else's body and it may or
may not kill you.
And I like the flu.
How many times have you shaken all these
hands after a show and then fingered a
girl without washing your hands
and now that I'm in ducks,
that goes without saying,
but I think everyone can relate to that.
Brian.
No,
I wash my hands after shows.
Yeah,
I washed my hands and also we,
you know,
I don't think about it that much,
but now that we're on the subject,
the microphone never gets
cleaned off like a gym.
You would never touch
equipment that didn't.
We occasionally get something
like show your face,
you kind of kiss it sometimes.
How many times do you accidentally put
your mouth or you're making it sound
effecting your and your your sucks.
And I get the most who's face,
I get it all up in the Mike all the time.
And Jill,
you know and like you're sterilize I
think never touched him with alcohol and
really they should.
We not,
now that I think about it,
maybe this guy's thing,
maybe I'll go Todd glass on everyone
and have them change the lighting and
sterilize.
The worst case scenario is these
things and he's foam thing.
This is just a receptical we're spitting
into that fucking thing and there's
like growing all kinds
of weird funky shit.
I bet if we had a microphone and we
looked at what's actually going on in the
foam of this microphone,
I suppose we'd be fucking terrified.
Oh yeah.
It'd be like
the clouds of Venus or whatever.
There'd be every manner
of thing growing in there.
That'd be pretty cool.
Taking all that DNA though.
You know how many people have talked
into that microphone and David Lee Roth?
Yeah.
I wonder how,
how long does that stick around?
Forever.
That's fine.
I think like for like spit,
it's gotta be pretty fresh.
You can't use a hundred year old spit.
Like,
you know,
if somebody's sucked on a
flute a hundred years ago,
I really doubt that.
Go and get some DNA off.
That's a good question
and I can't answer it,
but I want it off what you're just saying.
I was in Philly like a year or two
ago and I went to independence hall.
Right.
And they got the several drafts of
the declaration of independence,
the pre drafts before the one that we all
know and it says on the explanation on
the wall,
um,
George w a Benjamin Franklin and George
Washington is sweat and DNA is all over
this because they were like
this over it with pans writing.
And so I wonder if the spit lasts
because they were according to this,
it's like them touching it and their hair
landing on it and then sweating on it
was enough to,
you could extract.
It's definitely DNA in the future
if it hasn't been created yet.
Right.
If we can't pick it up now.
Whether it would be a
whole read out of them,
you know,
and we'll come a complete DNA molecule
or whether it would just be some of it,
I dunno.
But they were like,
oh Benjamin Franklins Dnas all over this.
Then like literally,
and I was like,
that's kind of exciting to think
about them just sitting there going,
I'm going to win in the court.
How do you spell you know,
course and you know,
match cause there's all these scratch
outs on it and ink and I'm touching it and
poor wiping techniques.
Well like that they didn't know hygiene.
The thing I think about when
you look at the old even brush,
no,
the thing about old paintings,
uh,
is you know that someone's,
you know,
the physical act of that's always
that to me that brings the pass back
instantly.
Cause it's like the genuine article.
If someone made a painting 500 years ago,
like you see a Davinci or something,
he certainly went,
you know,
and had paint on his face and,
and touch you with his hands and
put the brushes and you know,
got up to it and I stood back from it.
And then,
you know,
you're seeing the completed article but
the process that went into it is like
any plastic cart.
Yeah.
It isn't the immediacy of them making it,
it's kind of fascinating how once you
give something a name like Dna and it
becomes a normal part of your discussion,
it,
you,
you kind of forget how crazy.
Just being able to lick something and
leave fucking DNA is the idea that your a
stamp,
like you're sending a bill and you lick
it and you see that stamp that has your
fucking genetic markers on it and
they can identify you really well,
like down to like in the high nine days,
right?
It's like not a hundred but we know it's
you bitch and they take these fucking,
these saliva samples and all
sorts of different samples.
They can get DNA off of skin hair,
but did she get it?
But here's the hair thing.
Did you hear that?
The hair science,
like there's a good
percentage of it is bullshit.
Yeah.
Was actually invented by the FBI and
responsible for hundreds of convictions
where the doctors like war
fucking lab coat and said,
without a doubt 100% of these
came from the same person or it's,
again,
it goes back 20 years since
they started the program.
I read about it last weekend.
Scandalous.
It's not just scandalous.
It's horrific.
People were put to death.
Yeah.
They were people who were
put to death for crimes.
Who the fuck knows if they
were guilty or weren't guilty?
But if the tipping point
was this hair thing,
that's gotta be murder,
right?
Right.
That's merge the state murdering pits.
That's murder.
Why can't,
why can't we charge them with murder?
Will we try?
You think anything will come of it?
Um,
I think it's a shit storm.
It went away right after I first saw it.
Um,
but that's definitely the kind
of thing you have hearings about.
I think,
you know what [inaudible] programs,
things like that.
There's a fundamental huge
flaw in the system and the one,
the,
the fucking fundamental flaw of the
justice system is there's winning and
losing.
And when people get involved
in winning and losing,
they cheat.
They lie,
they steal,
they want to win because winning becomes
more important than anything else,
especially the good guys.
Because the good guys want to win.
Winning becomes more important than even
justice and truth because along the way
they develop,
they develop this attitude like,
look,
if I'm going after them,
they're already fucking
guilty of something else.
I know who's guilty,
especially when they're dealing with like
young kids that might have fucked up a
few times,
been to juvenile home.
I went to jail.
Like they'll,
they will literally cause crimes like,
but give people sentences
that they don't deserve.
Lock them up with
fucking planted evidence.
Like this is not,
it's not an uncommon thing
that only existed in a movie.
If we saw it in real life,
you'd be like,
oh right.
If we saw someone planting a gun on a
murder suspect or a a murder victim,
we wouldn't even think twice.
We would like,
of course they did it.
These people do this.
Sometimes it's not.
And everyone who becomes a cop is just
the one thing that everyone who becomes a
cop has in common is they're all people.
No,
that's still one thing.
And so that alone would let you believe
that most people should never be fucking
cops.
Like dump.
The vast majority of people should
never be trusted with that kind of
responsibility.
No Way.
That kind of power and then
when that gets a B is like,
you know,
now we've seen that the,
the last six months,
last two days that the,
the police state,
the overfunding,
the militarization,
the absolute lack of code when it comes
to black people or the underclass.
And then,
then it just piles up,
you know,
then the,
now we see it though more and more
now we're highly keenly tuned into it,
especially,
uh,
Walter Scott
got aced on video phone
horribly a couple of weeks ago.
But what is that?
Uh,
the,
the guy in,
um,
which town was it in?
Walter Scott and from her,
it's on the video,
you see the cop put slugs
and the guy who got shot,
it was running away a bit.
She had a pork.
Oh God.
So like now we're real
acutely aware that cops,
like you say,
our people and panic sheet people go
crazy with the use their situation they're
in.
They develop personal animosity for
this person they're trying to take out
because it becomes a competition,
becomes a competition of arresting them.
Then it becomes a competition
of convicting them.
It becomes us against them and even if
you're a great guy and you're the perfect
guy for being a cop,
you always have to be on guard of some
fucking asshole trying to shoot you or
jumping on you and punchy.
When you're arresting people,
you have to always be on your complete
red alert because we've all seen those
videos of cops that were like pulling
people over and then they got shot or
pulling people over it.
They've seen the one where the woman
pulls the guy over and the guy beats the
shit out of the woman in front of his
daughter and his daughter's screen
stopped.
Daddy stopped.
He knocks her out and
beats the shit out of her.
When she's unconscious,
it's horrific.
It just shows you,
first of all,
you can't have a lone woman
by herself in that scenario.
I mean,
we all,
everyone wants to believe in equal rights.
The,
there's no physical equality
that just doesn't exist.
And if you're going to be a woman and
you're going to be in a situation where
you have to arrest a big physical man,
you can't let them get anywhere near you
ever can't let them get it anywhere in
here.
Yeah,
you,
you have to make sure that
everybody that's around you,
whether it's a other cops are,
they know what's going on.
They know where you are right now because
it's highly likely that this guy's
gonna make an irrational decision
to just beat the fuck out of you.
And if you don't get to your gun and time,
you're done.
And that's the case with men too.
So those men have to
constantly be worried about it.
They was the constantly,
when they're,
so,
they're always fucking
freaking out and tense.
It's almost a job that no one can do.
Well,
how do you,
how do you do it every day and,
and measure the justice every day.
And then when you see how shit the
system is and when you see how even the
people you are arresting and they have
to live amongst their life's not so hot
and you know what I mean?
You'll either find out
of you're arresting,
you should feel sorry for her
at both ends of the spectrum.
Because on the one hand,
like when you saw that Ferguson report,
the mandate from the city was you go
out and you'd get those fines because
that's how,
that's how we generate
income in this town.
You go out and arrest people,
you pull people over for license plates,
lights,
any old miner it for being black,
just whatever.
You just make that happen.
And so in the report at said they were
getting pressured to be those kinds of
cops that had to just
minor infractions where,
how the city was making his money.
That's so crazy.
That's a completed version of how we
perceive what the police were supposed to
do because we're paying the taxes,
blah,
blah.
So glorified revenue collecting.
Right,
and that,
but that puts something on
them that they didn't sign it.
Exactly.
You know what I mean?
Like when the troops have to defend money,
positions and interests for our
country,
that's when I get huffy.
You know like people are like,
right,
he should be for the troops.
I'm like,
I'm all for the chiefs.
You put them in poisonous danger with
shit that's not tested or know a body
armor or poorly armored vehicles that
get blown up by iads and stuff and that's
our fault.
You know what I mean?
You're,
that's the government being malfeasant
and not protecting the people.
It's asking them to do something
that's more than you signed up.
Now imagine if the cops,
the soldiers rather also
how to write tickets.
They had to collect money
from an essence they here,
right?
They didn't essence they do,
but you can imagine they also have to
deliver money situation where not only did
they have to go and fight wars,
but they also had the ticket.
These people pull over.
You look,
if once it happens,
then that's what it is.
And that's the problem with cops.
Like we can't think of a time where a
cop wouldn't be riding speeding tickets,
but it's fucking ridiculous.
You're making a cop do that.
Either someone's violating the law,
which means they needed to be brought
into jail or it's not that big a deal.
It's one or the other.
You can't just take money from people
because they touched the gas pedal a
little too hard,
but they do.
And parking fines,
I mean la,
you know,
I lived in San Francisco and London,
the three places I've
lived and parking is,
you know,
that's the whole income of the city.
Yeah,
yeah.
Parking's giant.
If they made free parking and didn't
write out parking tickets and then you
know,
they can make a little bit
of money from the change,
but they bank on you fucking up.
Oh yeah,
they do.
What is it?
60 bucks to go over the meter.
$69 60 and then if you don't
pay it in like two weeks,
I had immediately jumps to like 150
and you don't pay that for like a week.
That goes to like 300 we used to throw
them in our glove box car before that
happened.
And when I lived in San Francisco,
I had a crappy Chevy Vega that like he
had to put two quarts of oil in every
day.
And you know,
every,
nothing worked.
But unless you've got a thousand tickets,
the first year I lived in San Francisco
and I threw them all in the glove box.
And finally a bench warrant was issued
and I was hired to go appear in front of
a judge.
And at that point,
this is like 1980 it was like
$1,500 worth of $5 tickets.
Right?
Or Wow.
And they went,
she went like,
what is your problem?
And I'm sorry,
your honor.
She goes,
well,
what are you going to do?
And I'm like,
oh no,
I don't have any money.
You know,
she,
she went 450 get outta here.
You know?
Wow.
So I think I painted over
like a couple of months.
I didn't even have $450 so you know,
I paid like my car got booted once got
booted because it didn't pay the tickets,
parking tickets.
Did you have to call someone
to come and do it or,
I think I had to go
somewhere and pay some money.
It was a long time ago.
It was in the 90s I remember it was in la.
I got the boot.
Yup.
And in London they took the car up and
put it on a truck and take it away.
Wow.
Whoa assholes.
You can't just take someone's
car because they owe you money.
The car's worth way more than
the fucking parking ticket.
It's astounding.
I found out the other day I was going
through my mail and I had almost thrown it
away that I guess when I was in San Diego,
I went on one of those highways
that I guess was a toll road,
but they don't even tell you or
there they might have told you.
But it's real easy to
just get on and get off.
And not even know you're on it.
They take a picture of your license.
He didn't pay and I
didn't even know about it.
And uh,
it,
I owe like a lot of money because
I didn't have a bunch of times.
I forget now it's,
it's cause it was like two,
like two months old or three
months old or something like that.
And I still kept going up again.
Yeah.
I got one from Illinois after Christmas.
I did a Gig in Arlington or somewhere
and I went on a toll road and I was like,
did I pay,
you know,
I just went through a thing and then like,
was I supposed to stop because
there was no people manning.
That's a trick.
People manning it and
then like there were,
I can see there were lanes where
people had discs and I thought,
oh shit.
As soon as I went through
it and sure enough,
a week later my wife goes,
when were you in Carbondale,
Illinois?
Or you know,
or whatever.
And I went,
I was driving from Chicago and I
drove in a double room and she's like,
well it's $25 or whatever,
you know?
Yeah.
That's uh,
that's that thing where they used to do,
when you go through a red light and they
would take a picture of your license
plates and that illegal,
yeah,
that was deemed illegal.
Oh Wow.
They still use it in
west Hollywood and stuff.
Do they still use it to see
them but other day I haven't.
Um,
I don't know if they use them though.
I don't know if they still write tickets
because I'm pretty sure they deem that
unconstitutional because it was a third
party that was profiting off of it.
It was a private company.
So like you really didn't
have to pay those tickets.
Like when you would get one of those
tickets and it would say you ran a red
light,
we want a hundred bucks.
Like they were getting the money,
like the money wasn't going to
the state and everybody's like,
Hey,
what the fuck are you doing?
You're going to have a private
company that also profits from it.
I mean the state must have
gotten a piece of the action,
but it was easier for
them to just farm it out.
Well,
I mean
that's why there's an alien billion
zillion people in prison in this country.
It's not cause that many people have
done anything worthy of being in prison.
Yeah.
And we'll end the function of that whole
system where someone's a winter and
someone's a loser.
Like when you see people win when they
win in court and they found not guilty.
And that's like the three
pointer of all three pointers.
You know,
if you're about to go
to jail and you're like,
remember when Oj Simpson,
when they said not guilty?
And he was like,
really?
Really,
Oh,
you can see that.
Look on his face.
That guy,
I mean he was trying to play poker,
but he hit the lottery.
He knew it and he won three pointer,
Swish,
nothing but net home run over the
building into the parking lot.
Pray King car when,
I mean he won.
Right.
That you can't have winners and losers
when it comes to laws and court.
That's just too crazy.
That's weird that he didn't
just hide after that.
Like it was such a huge win
that why would you even,
when did you just like not leave the
house for the rest of your life and no,
he didn't want,
I mean I think he didn't want anybody
to think that he's in jail now.
He's in jail now for felonies.
Well he's in jail now for,
I think they called it kidnapping
and something along those lines.
Some armed something that,
that was the Caper in Vegas.
Right.
That was the thing in Vegas where he
was a victim of someone taking his stuff
and selling it.
Like some of his memorabilia got sold by
this guy and he wanted to get his stuff
back.
So we brought some dudes who brought
some guns and as soon as that's the case,
you're fucks.
Yeah.
And the government came in and they go,
dude,
we've been looking for an
excuse to put you away.
And so they just locked him up.
But he's fucked psyche.
Say it with my life.
And now I say it like when
you know how Hollywood is.
So,
especially young actresses,
they get out,
jog dad,
they go crazy.
The next thing you know you've seen a
picture of them and then they're in the
street upside down and
then they stay here and,
or maybe they go to rehab for a month
and we always go move to France,
moved somewhere with,
they'll appreciate you.
You're still a star in Europe or whatever,
no matter what.
And in other countries,
they don't look at it the same way,
but why stay here under the scrutiny
of TMZ and all of a sudden was getting
their bench.
That fucking Rosetta stone
is a pain in the ass.
If you want to really laugh French,
it takes too long.
They're lazy,
they want to do coke and get fucked.
They are lazy eye.
I'm like,
Mike,
when Michael Jackson,
when the shit hit the fan,
he likes stayed and you know,
and you think,
well eventually country man
did [inaudible] which was like,
wait,
what I,
which is really weird cause you're
going to a slave state dictatorship,
you know,
uh,
Mrh that's run by royal people who have,
there's no like,
yeah.
You know,
democracy.
Like who was the idea there?
No one gets to vote.
Why the fuck would he move there?
Why don't you give me protected
by rich people that he felt safe?
That must be right.
That must've been when all the
legal shit was hitting the fan.
It's a wall of rich people.
God,
that's terrifying.
My couldn't,
we will have your back.
And my joke was he
staying at the Iman side,
a boy hotel.
Now I just feel bad about him.
You know,
like I watched the video
sometimes and think,
God damn,
he really was the fucking gifted,
you know?
Oh yeah.
But I mean,
how about the fact that it was just,
he was made a star when he was a young,
young,
young boy,
his psyche,
of course it does.
It's impossible.
You can't go through
life learning about the,
the trials and tribulations of being a
human being amongst other human beings on
earth.
If you never feel like you're
one with all those people around,
you know,
I know this from five
cry on all that money,
man,
who,
well,
I feel about him the same way I feel
about if you've seen that video of those
young kids in Baltimore that
robbed the RT camera crew,
they robbed them on camera
while I was riding was going on.
Dude,
you've ever seen it?
No.
You gotta you gotta play this.
We gotta play this,
these guys from our t,
first of all those people from rt,
that's where Abby Martin,
uh,
started out and they have fucking balls.
Been people dismiss our tea
because it's rushing owned,
but they're reporters do
some ballsy fucking shit.
And,
um,
they were,
while all
the protests were going
on for the young man.
What is Freddie,
what was his name?
This is the new,
was Freddie Gray's at it?
Was it?
I can't remember.
I don't remember.
W the,
it was a young man that
was in police custody.
Uh,
and there was some discrepancy of how
he died and he died from trauma and they
think that the police
beat this guy to death.
So there's this huge,
huge backlash because people can only
see so many black dudes get shot by cops
are choked by cops or beaten by
cops or shot running away unarmed.
They can only see so much of that and
now they've hit this breaking point.
I hope so.
I hope this changes things
going on since Eric Garner
and now it's been rolling on.
So it's the fucking beginning.
No skyline.
But you know.
Yeah,
yeah.
But like everybody who
wants there to be no crime,
you got to think about like we,
we will all sympathize with poor Michael
Jackson born to this crazy family of
entertainers and made famous when he was
young and had a predilection allegedly
for young boys is poor fucker.
And it's crazy.
Twisted childhood every day.
All across the country and ghettos.
There are horrific scenarios playing out.
The babies are growing up and then it's
not all babies is not all poor people,
but we're not talking just poor.
We're talking poor that are surrounded
by desperate people pour that are
surrounded by people that
have grown up doing crime.
Like their whole life
has been about crime.
Everyone around them is involved in crime.
You're gonna run into those
people occasionally where
a good percentage of the
families in and out of
jail where it seems normal.
It seems rational.
How about that person?
How about that person when
she's got to go to college,
when she's 18 w what?
What fucking horrific
PTSD does she have from,
from growing up in the worst sections
of Compton or Inglewood or wines.
Yeah.
That's why education is important
to spend on the law enforcement.
If they don't even more intense than that,
it has to be taken to a totally different
place because it's not education terms
of like come in,
sit down,
we're going to teach you about George
Washington and his fucking cherry tree.
It's got to be this like completely
invasive supportive system that eliminates
ghettos.
Like you have to eliminate them
if you don't eliminate ghettos.
And I don't mean make it
so that they gentrify it,
no one can afford living in it.
Cause that's how the
eliminate ghettos and lesbian,
they say they've been plenty of ghettos
eliminated and a lot of towns I've lived
in,
New York City has a problem in
San Francisco because New York,
there's so much.
The real estate is where it's so much
that they could just come in and there's
an apartment building
that's like old and shitty.
That space is worth
ungodly amounts of money.
If they can convert it
to high end apartments.
I just disappear just like that.
Oh No.
And then people are gone.
No,
you mean improve neighborhoods
where people live?
Yeah.
You going to things like parks and
resources and all of the above cases.
Kids can go,
yeah,
community centers and
even then how do you get,
how do you penetrate the home?
You know,
how do you stop horrific
childhoods from emerging?
I mean how do you,
but as human beings it's like,
what are we w we are essentially this
giant community of people that denies it's
a community.
We have all these methods that we use
to keep ourselves apart from each other,
whether it's Republican or
Democrat or Islamic or Jewish.
All these little teams that we choose to,
but at the end of the day,
we're all just one giant race,
one super organism.
That's it.
And anything that's calendar that,
anything that's like counterintuitive
to that idea is unhealthy for us.
And well,
what's counterintuitive?
Ignore the worst spots.
Ignore it and get angry at them.
Ignore.
Ignore your hospital,
your cancer that you have in the,
the,
the biological fiber of your being.
Ignore that and get angry
at it for being that way.
Well,
I'll just pull yourself
up by your bootstraps.
They're strapping a staph infection,
you know,
I mean,
imagine if that's how you
looked at like a broken ankle.
You fucking pussy.
You look down at your broken ankle.
How about,
you know,
I'm will give the left ankle.
Left Ankle is fine.
Left ankles did the same fucking roads.
You will are,
it's actually a perfect analogy.
Yeah.
If you're running and you break one ankle,
you know,
does the good ankle go?
What bitch?
I fucking did the same
road I worked on this.
This isn't it.
This is not how it works
as a super organism.
You can't have places like
this scene in Baltimore.
Did you find the video?
Watch this video because you're going
to freak the fuck out because let's play
good.
He would give it a little volume.
Hopefully our teeth.
So these guys look at this.
Yeah.
So now you see these guys running?
Yep.
She stole it.
He stole her bag and the cops tackled
this guy and took the bag back.
So the cops saved or how ironic.
Wow.
Right.
Her crazy.
Everything in play.
Wow.
This video highlights a lot of shit,
doesn't it?
And it illuminates why
you fucking need police.
Okay,
there you go.
You just saw why you fucking need police.
You got your bag back.
Why?
Because the police caught the guy who
robbed you on air is that's a good ending.
Damn.
I mean it's a great ending
for the police.
That's like a fucking that
you would have to think.
That might be like a viral video.
You know?
You might have to think like
if the police were smart.
That's what let's like
kind of video you pull out,
have this really super ultra liberal
progressive chick getting robbed by black
dudes and then screaming,
give me back my bag.
She doesn't once dropping n bombs,
she's not,
my cell phone's in there.
You nigger shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Like she's super progressive.
Probably really smart.
You know,
brave journalists going in
there and she could say by cops.
It's crazy.
That's pretty crazy.
I think you're right that let,
letting the sickness of poverty just
go on and on and the country where we
really do have the money
to save everything.
That's real racism.
That's real.
And it's not just racist to black people.
It's racist to a gang of
different ethnicities that
are just completely ignored.
How about poor Asian communities?
There's a lot of like ultra poor Asian
immigrant communities in this country
ignored,
ignored.
Figure it out,
figure it out.
You're on your own.
And I don't even know what
the solution would be,
but I think there's a big part of the
prison system that's ingrained in these
bad neighborhoods.
If you're looking at a bad
neighborhood that's just,
there's crime has always been there.
Okay.
So that means police acted if
activity has always been there.
So then it becomes like the symbiotic
relationship between police activity and
crime and there's no incentive whatsoever
to try to slow it down other than cops
dying when cops get
shot and killed on the,
on the job.
That's like when a big push to like sort
of settle crime down and usually it's
just more arrests.
Yeah,
I mean that's the,
the no one looks at
like the inherent issue.
There's a,
there's a giant issue that there's winning
and losing shit of arresting people
and punishing them and
trying them and fight.
They found guilty or not guilty and up.
Yes or a no.
And a green or a red that
beat me becomes a game.
And that game,
no one in that game
wants the game to stop.
Well,
it's for profit because the prison
systems for profit and then on top of it,
there's no,
there's no equity at all.
All the bankers,
you know,
to make a huge analogy that
all the bankers and everyone
who ruined the economy
and everything,
none of them did any time and
no one ever laid a hand on them.
But people who commit small crimes and
petty crimes are always getting busted
and turn on a gene.
Edwards has a brilliant joke about that.
Here's a brilliant joke about that.
I don't want to give it away.
I can't even say the punchline,
but he's got a brilliant joke about
comparison comparing thugs to bankers,
right?
Fucking a lariat.
My Jack has no black teenager ever ruin
the economy on me and no black teenager
ever invaded Iraq.
I was like you said with
the accentuation Iraq bitch.
That's why,
uh,
the smartest man in the world is
like for a lot of other people.
Couldn't pull that off dude.
Your sense of humor.
It's just like,
just,
you know,
there's some like unique sort of,
uh,
styles of humor.
Like Brody Stevens is like my favorite
example because the shit that Brody says,
it's only funny if you're Brody Stevens.
Yeah.
But if you're Brody it's brilliant.
He was fucking destroying one night
like a month ago at the comedy store.
You know he does that late
night spot after midnight.
You know like all the comics
have already gone off.
The show has been going on since
nine o'clock everyone's exhausted.
Whoever's there is a
glutton for punishment,
right.
20 people in the audience and then comics
just start filtering in and Brody does
like 45 minutes.
I put some of it on Instagram
where he's playing drums.
He's got someone's singing the
lawsuit Tisa animal and it's just,
it's,
it's the Brody show for the
last hour of the comedy store.
It's the Brody show when he does it,
it's him and Brian Holtzman.
Those are the masters at that late spot.
And Don Barris to Don
Buress is like Don Berrett.
Buress is like the master of debacle.
Like when,
if you want to see something absolutely
ridiculous happen in the crowd.
Late night at the comedy store.
If Don bears is on stage,
it's likely to happen.
He's the master that like becoming
the ring leader of the crazies.
He's just so comfortable
with crazy people too.
That's awesome.
If you have the will to do that,
you want to go in late and
I didn't and strike it down.
Well you don't want it for Brody.
That's like the perfect kind of set
course course cause he needs to be in the
moment.
He's very environmental.
Yeah.
But he's a perfect example there.
There's,
there's plenty of video
because it's a reduction.
He's playlists,
drums making kissy faces and isn't got
a guy out of the audience right next to
him playing the tambourine
and people don't their,
you know,
was people in the front row
that her from fucking Idaho.
I've come to the world famous
comedy store and they're like,
what are we seeing?
But what they're seeing is probably like
one of the coolest things you're ever
going to get chance to see.
This is completely free form.
This one dude is just really entertaining
and just having fun off the cuff
constantly.
You know,
that plays it so addicting.
They go to a man I had to take a night
off last night just hanging out that the
comedy store and they have that new bar
open now in the back or did it open?
Yeah,
it's like it's a new green room bar.
Yeah.
It's critical.
It's like this really cool little VIP
bar and then they're just cleaning it up.
It's uh,
it's amazing how that new GM has just
really taken control of that is bad mother
fucker.
Yeah.
We knew him from back in
the Tempe Improv days.
He's always been cool.
Show Eric.
Yeah.
Eric and Adam.
Well who started it?
Who's,
who's the big cheese over there?
Eric.
Eric is the big chess,
I don't even know Adam is the what?
Uh,
booking general manager type duties.
Yeah,
he started to,
yeah.
It's just like they needed people that
had some experience in comedy clubs that
weren't crazy and they
never got that before.
Everybody that used to run the comedy
store was completely out of their fucking
mind,
you know?
And Adam is just such a laid back,
easy going,
dude.
He has like a great
relationship with comics,
like all the comics that know him.
Like it's always like,
what's up dude?
It's like,
oh,
like a genuine friendship
of relationship with him.
It is the norm Macdonald show and he
also works with Norm Macdonald also.
So he's like friends with the uh,
the comics,
but he's just a good dude.
Just a good dude to have around too.
He's fun.
So like he like,
he genuinely liked to see him,
which wasn't the case for that place ever.
You know?
It's a weird spot,
man.
Did still there.
It's still right there on sunset.
Yeah,
east of Los Anica in the craziest spot
in all of the world of entertainment.
That strip,
that's what were the
whiskey is we're Hendrix.
He used to play and the doors
used to fucking throw down.
I mean that's right down the street
from where River Phoenix died.
You know,
that's up the street,
man.
I'm not that,
that one that's still the Roxy where
Sam Kennison filmed his HBO special and
it's right next door to
the rainbow bar and grill,
which is like you want to go back in time,
you want to go to the 80s
they're there,
they're fucking drunk as shit
and they had a good time.
It's a,
that's a wild ass part
of part of the country,
not just part of town.
Yeah it is.
I don't play this.
I haven't played the store in ages.
I remember seeing you outside
there once and you are videotaping.
This is the backroom still
all red and coke Denny,
the back room.
Um,
that oh you like the
green room behind the,
the comedy store or behind
the main room rather.
Yeah,
it's a red and white walls.
Yeah.
It's kind of weird.
Like old school neon shit in a fake piano.
The fake piano,
which is probably seeing more lines.
How many rails?
Any object in the known universe.
Even now,
one of the legs is broken.
So like if you lean on it and you
have like a big pile of cocaine,
it just flies on
cane.
Sam Kinison is rolling in his grave.
It was always these crazy rumors to that
there's a tunnel from the back of the
comedy store.
It goes under the comedy store and it
goes up to crest hill where they had the
comic's house because when
they bought the house,
they bought the comedy store
together as one package.
Cause it was like Bugsy Siegel's place,
right?
So they used to live like right up on
crest hill or somebody you didn't sneak
under and there's a fucking tunnel.
So like if does stuff,
fuzz is,
hey,
we've got to get natal fucked off paints
and get getting the tunnel and just run
up to the hill.
Tucked themselves in the bed.
What officer?
I've been in bed this whole
evening notion back then.
There's no DNA.
They couldn't,
you know,
of course it will touch this door knob.
Stupid.
What?
There's an essence of
you on the door knob.
See we brought it back around.
Yeah,
the DNA at the comedy store
and coke on that table.
I'm sure there's residue from the,
did you ever do the cocaine
great groups I have done.
Have you?
I have.
I'm not doing it now,
but have you ever,
did you ever go through
a period where we went,
I don't think I should
do this stuff anymore?
I know because it was never,
I never seriously did it
a lot because it's not,
I'm more of a pothead.
I know the feeling jacked,
uh,
wasn't for me.
It's I have to drink gallons of Lod Cath.
I do cocaine and I,
I'll drink anyway.
Yeah.
Because I can't sleep.
Oh.
Just to kind of calm down,
you know,
like the basically coke is there.
She can drink as much as
you can humanly get down.
My joke was because he'd go to the dealer.
So I used to do a real long routine
about cocaine because George Bush said,
w Bush said he didn't remember.
But then I did coke.
Yeah.
Someone said,
wow,
did you do cook?
Kenny goes,
I don't remember.
And I was like,
Oh,
you remember if you did coke?
There's no forgetting it.
Even if he just did it once.
And then I said elaborate
measures have to be enacted.
You have to,
first of all,
my distinct recollection is you
have to go to one assholes house
and then he tells you about the
quality of it and you're like quality.
I've debased myself by being here.
I would snort,
drain off of fucking midget right now.
I go,
let's get this going.
I got a knight to ruin than someone drags.
You face down a stair,
you go to Denny's and spend the whole
time barfing in the bathroom cause she
can't eat.
Someone drags.
You face down the stairs and you call
someone you booty call someone at four in
the morning that you met
at a Yaz concert in 1994
well that's a strong booty call.
That's a,
that's a hail Mary.
I said,
you know,
that's just disingenuous to say
you don't remember doing cocaine.
Well,
it's disingenuous because
you would remember whether
or not you have done it and
you guys,
if you haven't done it,
you'd remember all the time.
I've never done coke
because that comes up.
If you have a conversation
with people once a year,
someone will say,
Hey,
have you ever tried Qualia foods?
Like,
no,
I never fucked with that.
I don't fuck with pills.
Like what about yeah we do.
It's always have those sort of
conversation or women I'm sure have those
conversations too and you would
know whether or not you took coke.
There's a decision
involved in taking cars.
This elaborate ritual
that goes on with it.
There's all the chest rather than
talking about it and acting like it's
important and it's a cause.
It's expensive.
And there's this like saying,
have you ever had a shot of
wild Turkey memorably go,
I'm might've.
Right.
What's,
what's the difference?
Who Does?
Why?
What side?
Jim Beam is that wild Turkey?
Is that different Shit,
you know you'd have those conversations
like that makes sense but not,
I don't remember whether
or not I did coke.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Bitch.
Do you remember whether you've
ever had a drink of alcohol?
I don't remember what,
yeah,
fuck the flood.
No,
you either did or you don't.
It can be.
It can be fun that I think when you
base the night around it and everything
becomes we have to do more and more more
and then at the end of the night when
there's no more and then it's a sad time.
That's always the sad part.
Just like it's not a
positive drug that way.
Whereas pot at a certain point you're
going to pull the rip cord because you're
just too high or you fall asleep or for
your time or we all go to
Taco bell or whatever it is.
You know,
it's a different kind of tired too.
You know?
I've never done a coke,
but the stimulants,
any kind of stimulant [inaudible]
the next day racked I did ecstasy,
which is like very much like a
stimulant that especially I think,
I think the shit I had was probably not
100% pure cause I've heard people say
that if you don't,
if feel like if you,
if you don't try it like pure,
you really don't know what
the actual effects is.
Speeding.
There wasn't.
To me it ends that way.
I was definitely awake.
I definitely stayed awake
for a long fucking time.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
I didn't think it was that speedy,
but then someone told me that it's
like really frequently cut with it.
I'm like,
well,
how do you know you're
getting it from a drug dealer?
Right.
And that's inherently like
a big part of the problem,
right?
You're getting it illegally so you,
it's,
you're at risk.
You don't really know what
the fuck you doing was.
If you buy it from someone
in a bar or something,
then you're completely taking
it on faith that they're,
have the goodwill to not poison you.
Yeah.
Well that's what I was getting.
Well,
it's going to ask you about the difference
between stuff that's cut and stuff
that's not cut.
I don't think I've ever
had rock star staff,
you know,
and I hear stories about it.
You know,
I've had friends who've done coke with
famous people and junk and they go,
oh,
it was so pure and so good.
And then they delete and then evidently
then you don't sweat and act like an
asshole other dental.
He then you're the life of the
Goddamn party in your area.
Lighting ladies cigarettes and quipping
off bone marrows and absolutely being
the event of the season.
Uh,
no,
I think whenever you're doing it it's
just cause you want to get jacked and
drank a bunch.
And then we had asked,
you know,
hanging out with a girl and you're like,
oh come here,
I got cocaine.
There's that.
She will go,
I think that's rape is
technically kind of rapey
a little quick in there like
chocolate quick to make a chocolate,
cocaine.
They chicks love that.
Wow.
These are some tips I cocaine
tip or a chocolate shake mix.
A little bit of quick in there and it
tastes like smells like chocolate when you
snort it.
Girls Love.
Have you actually done this?
You ever I take fruit loops
and coat them with ecstasy and,
no,
that's to what I was going to ask is is
there a difference between like needing
alcohol when you have
cut coke to not cook,
Cook cause you,
do you remember Tom Sawyer from uh,
[inaudible] as well as I remember anyone.
I'm sending him a copy
of the book tomorrow.
Fuck for the elaborate inscription.
Tell him I said he always just
talk about rock star coke.
Like it was the god damn like it was.
That's what he'd say.
Yeah.
That's where I got the expression.
Yeah,
we would talk about doing it
with like Kinison or rock.
He did it with like a bunch of like
maybe it was Robin might've been robbing.
Yeah,
whoever the fuck he did it with.
But he would talk about how it was like,
it was like the best Asian massage
ever with a builtin happy ending.
No,
no questions asked and you just
sleep like a baby afterwards.
He made it sound like this wonderful
experience that you needed to try.
And then afterwards the big things
like you could just go to bed.
No problem.
You can write.
I'm like,
how the fuck is that possible?
I guess cause I don't know
because is it a completely,
I don't know like what the properties are,
but I'm assuming it's,
since it's a numbing agent,
it's an analgesic or like
an anesthetic almost.
So really what it's getting stepped on
with his crappy speed and other shit that
the additives is what
Jack Shoe I'm guessing.
Yeah,
but that never had like
if you went to a pharmacy,
what a pharmacist would have would be
pharmaceutical cocaine and that would be
very pure.
And then that's an experiment.
Let's let's get a pharmacist on the show.
Joe,
did you know that Coca Cola
still uses coca leaves?
Yeah.
No.
Amazing.
It's part of their flavor.
I don't think Pepsi does,
but Coca Cola uses actual coca leaves
like and they extract medical grade
cocaine from it and then they you,
they like the same company that
that does this for Coca Cola.
They also sell medical grade
cocaine to like hospitals and shit.
Cause a numbing agent.
I don't know what they use it for,
man.
I don't,
I don't understand.
But apparently they make you,
it doesn't have anything to do that.
Psychoanalysis,
what is it?
Stuff that they,
a lidocaine like line of can.
It's like cocaine's.
It's not an autistic brother.
I don't think I've ever had.
Maybe if I'd done the rock star Cook,
I'd be advocating it more.
To me it always just seemed
like the people who did it.
Whenever the people that I wanted
to roll with the yellow line,
the inside of the nose and medic ropes
membranes before certain medical.
Well Huh.
I wonder why this is
bleeding and swelling.
Yeah,
so it's actual cocaine,
not lidocaine.
No,
she's interesting.
Cocaine hydrochloride.
Well,
I don't know if you remember how that one
person I hung out with that used to do
liquid cocaine and it was just
like a little spray model,
like a Flonase bottle.
He's just like,
and you just,
that's how you did it.
He's just trying to get it into your
memory and as quickly as possible and by
putting it in in Lakewood,
you're absolutely,
what kind of liquid would you put it into
that you could just spray in your nose
like that?
That's how it came.
It came like I can't let
that atomizer spray down.
Wow.
That's why one of the a shelf.
It might be worth trying.
I don't know.
I,
like I said,
the older I get to you,
I don't want my heart
to explode or anything.
You know,
real issue that they say is a,
with the way they process
cocaine from the coca leaves.
But the coca leaves themselves are
not only not dangerous for you,
but really common and kind of healthy.
I mean,
they have like Fido nutrients and there's
some properties it for thousands of
years in South America.
It rots the holy fuck out of your teeth,
son.
It rots the holy fuck out of your teeth.
You see those dudes that chew
those coca leaves all the time.
It might be that they like doing coca
leaves so much they don't ever bother
brushing.
Yeah.
They probably don't have really good
dental care for chewing on how they built
the Inca empire because it's a mild
stimulant and just stick it in your cheek
like chill.
Yeah,
I need just keep it in there.
And it allows you,
because it restricts the blood
vessels to work at higher altitudes,
more,
you know,
there's all these,
they were able to build massive cities and
the higher altitude tincture at precarious
fucking lofty heights all through the
empire for thousands of miles.
And it certain that they're all,
all the workers.
Well that's one of the daily,
yeah,
without a doubt.
I mean there,
that's a really common thing today.
And the people who pick it,
they don't snort it.
They chew,
right?
Yeah.
They're all chew it.
It's like really common.
Like they have these bags of it and they
hand it to each other and they take it
and they grab it and they
stuffed it in their mouth.
Like,
look how much this guy's
got stuffed in his face.
Like a giant squirrel person,
you know,
that's what they do.
I mean,
if you were climbing and
the Andes and you wanted to,
I think,
feel better and not have
a altitude sickness,
the cocaine alleviates,
yeah.
For us who are not,
we're land inbound,
but it's not going to live
at 8,000 feet or whatever.
It's not cocaine,
cocaine leaves.
Yeah,
it's Coco,
Coco,
cocaine is the extract is the more
unnatural and it is fucked the same way
sugars fucked.
Like when you take sugar like regular
sugar and you pour it on your frosted
flakes,
you're just poisoning yourself.
You're just giving yourself sugar.
It tastes awesome.
Don't get me wrong when I hate it,
but you're giving yourself,
it's like a toxin at that level.
It's toxic,
it's bad,
it's actually bad for your body.
It can diminish your body's performance.
Your by your insulin levels
get off fucking out of whack.
Your body is like,
what is this?
Because you're not supposed
to have sugar in that form.
It's supposed to come attached to fiber
and watermelon and apples and all these
different fruits that we'd
normally get sugar from.
It's supposed to be,
there's like,
you know a relationship that these,
these,
these nutrients and the various aspects
of food I'll have to the actual piece of
food that they come from
when you just extract one,
you know,
good part of it like sugar or cocaine.
Like you're taking it out of the
whole symbiotic plant systems.
Cause isn't that like the story that know?
I just read this book,
I can't remember it.
It's called the six six drinks in the
history of the world and six drinks.
And they talked a lot
about coca cola in it.
Look at that shit.
Sugar's addictive is I bet it is.
And,
and the brain scans sugars.
It's the refining of everything and the
extracting of anything that's changed
the world,
right?
Like sugar is a giant moment in human
history when sugar becomes important
because then rum becomes important than
slavery and taking over the new world
and the,
you know,
the whole history of the new world
is built on cocaine and sugar.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean there's,
there's definitely good and bad with
all sorts of things that have ruined all
sorts of aspects of our world.
I mean,
for a long time people go to war for salt.
Absolutely.
Saul,
stop and think about precedes sugar as
the big item that everybody has to have.
So first march was it to the salt marshes
because that's what he's purchasing
the British fuck.
It's salt's a key
ingredient in human history.
And,
and people still say it
and now I'm getting boring,
but I was just gonna say
when they used to pay,
they paid people in Salt,
you're in salt and you're worth your salt.
The reason what do you
know why they do it?
You know,
what's all the properties of salt?
It absolutely replenishes
your body when you're,
you know,
working out.
And I guess the sodium is some sort of no,
go on.
Tell us it sounds or I'm
stumbling around now.
Those are all good.
But the big one is a preservation of food.
If you could take me and
my cover and salt and fish,
especially,
you cover it in salt,
it'll prevent bacteria from growing,
right?
Yeah.
So they would literally layer
these fish filets in stacks of,
of salt.
Like they would put salt,
put the fish down,
cover the fish with salt,
put a filet down,
cover that with salt
and they would be fine.
Like for days,
months,
you could ship.
That's how that's all.
All food was kept in those days.
It really lasts for months.
Well,
that horrible stuff all day.
Uh,
you know that they saw him,
cod,
salt,
cod and salt pork,
right.
You'd be salt the dickens out of the
pork and then just keep it forever,
isn't it under refrigeration?
Right.
So salt provided refrigeration for 10,000
zillion years and it was how you kept
food.
Yeah.
I mean it was like people
can't to this day go,
what do you just pour your
salt on your French fries?
People go to war for that shit.
It's a condiment.
You don't go to war for condiments,
but that's not what it was.
It was like going to Wal for refrigerator.
Harry met Sally in ancient Rome.
The big sauce was this fish sauce.
It tastes a lot like
Vietnamese fish tacos.
Very salty and Brown.
And it was like rendered fish that they
let it sit and then they through salt in
it,
but it kept,
wow.
He kept,
he could,
he could have it on your
shelf for a couple of weeks,
which in the ancient world,
you're buying food every day.
You're taking your bread to the baker,
the bigger breaks that you bring it back.
You know,
all of that has to be done on the day,
right.
You have to check in or whatever.
You're not going to the supermarket and
putting shit in the fridge for a billion
years.
So yeah,
you don't have a deep freezer.
We knew keep pot pies,
salt in cities,
like you said,
the,
the world flood over solve for ages
and amazing to think about today,
people were forced to work in
salt mines and died in them.
That was like a huge punishment for ages.
There's a mountain in Germany,
there's a mountain of salt.
Wow.
It's been redeeming Audi yet there's
a book called salt and it's very good.
Will you look up the book called Salt,
the guy who wrote it and they reduced
it just because of the world's need for
salt.
Yeah.
They just,
you know,
they dug it all down.
Like there was a,
there's two mountains and one in South
America I can't remember in the other.
And Mexico's it in Potosi and uh,
yeah,
there it is.
Salt a world history.
You really like it now because he it
down and he shows you the salt mines and
there's pictures of the Salt Mountain and,
uh,
and it has UN fucking believable.
I mean,
we were talking earlier today,
we were talking earlier today about not
having a smartphone would a big leap
that would be to go back to a flip phone,
but look at the fuck
people fought over salt.
That is so alien and spices,
right?
The reason why Columbus was coming there,
it is that the reason why a Columbus
was a mountain of salt w w came and I
didn't always talking about
Columbus even bloody show that it,
even Magellan.
And when he went around the world,
uh,
he sent five ships.
Uh,
they lost all of them.
They finally came back
with one three years later,
right?
Three years later.
But crappy shit with
18 guys sailed back in.
Well,
it all been underwritten by,
uh,
businessmen from Germany,
right?
Who underwrote Magellan's voyage.
There was enough spice in that
ship to pay for the whole trip.
A three year trip and losing 300
guys and five ships or whatever,
four ships.
Whoa there was it because
they brought back what,
like why,
don't know what they wanted on
that one nutmeg or whatever it was.
And they had to go all the way around
the world to on would east indies,
no electricity.
But she see that was the difference was
Magellan was going to prove you could go
that way.
Cause usually they went around India and
the horn and so that's how valuable it
was.
And that's why uh,
England,
Portugal and Spain were such giant powers,
the big spice.
And then when Spain
took over the new world,
there was a mountains of gold,
one in South American,
one a mountain of silver,
I mean a mountain of silver that they
made the Indians and killed them all.
Doing it.
Dig Out and all the gold and silver in
Asia is still in circulation is like
Spanish gold dug out of the new world.
That's insane.
There was a literal Mt.
Two of them.
One in South America
and one in Mexico types.
So credible a mountain.
Fuck.
It's not that long ago either.
You know,
1492 Columbus sailed the ocean blue.
That's not that long.
500 years ago.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's why Spain is a had money
and why giant and then comes the,
the uh,
what you might call it,
the reformation and after the inquisition
and now Europe becomes Europe and they
all start fighting each other and it's
really truly amazing what a small amount
of time that is in terms of like in
perspective with the human history,
human history,
just even perspective with it.
Everybody wants to go to the
beginning of the universe.
13.7 billion.
God,
we don't even have to go that far.
Let's go to biological life.
Yeah.
And then human beings have been
around just a small amount of time.
And in that small amount of time,
the amount of change that we've seen
just in 200 years is so mind blowing.
And we're talking about like going back
to flip phones being like some big,
big fuck up.
I can't believe I couldn't do it.
Okay,
good.
I'm gonna just rub two sticks,
dude.
I need periscope periscoping all the time.
It's huge for my career.
You could go back to salt,
keeping your,
your food alive with Senate.
I'm going to start lining everything.
Like there's going to be an
asshole out there to tell that.
I bet there's assholes out
there doing it right now.
Oh yeah.
There are guys who make their
own axes and shit at Chisel.
Everything.
The good thing about now is
now you get to see people.
What are the things you thought we lost?
Like you know,
blacksmiths and saddle makers
are back and making stuff.
You know,
like everybody's relearning
all these old crafts,
how to be a no one knows how to like,
uh,
you know,
boil metal or whatever and be,
make all those ancient things
that were so necessary.
If you didn't have blacksmiths
250 years ago in this country,
even a hundred years ago,
a wagon,
wheels,
everything.
Horses,
you know,
your guns,
the tongs,
the tools you worked with,
you had to take it into him and he'd
fix it and he'd give it back to this
something really quick.
Carrying swords and spears.
I mean,
on paper.
Something really cool about that,
right?
Someone in your group
had to be a metal worker,
you know what I mean?
Someone in your unit worked metal and
you'd heat up a thing at night and bang,
Bang,
fix everybody's guns.
And there's a guy who made your furniture.
It was a guy with a to the wood and
sawed it down and make your table.
Yup.
By Ham Day.
Yeah.
Wow.
And everybody's table was a slightly
different because they really were just
marking it with pencils,
song into the wood and
you could see sometimes.
Then you got to places
like when they have,
you know,
our artisans making,
I don't know,
I,
I'm not going to go to a revolutionary
ward village to watch them churn,
butter or nothing,
but I don't like,
like super stupid old school
and making shit with your hands.
But I'm,
I love when I love watching people
make sure that I don't even give a fuck
about,
yeah.
Like violins.
I don't play the violin,
but I watched some show about them making
violins and the wood did they choose
and the harmonics of the wood and the,
I mean when you look at a
really truly expensive violin,
I mean that is a goddamn
functional workable.
Absolutely.
I don't even,
I don't play any instruments.
No.
And I think the musicians you buy,
those hot high end ones
are reverent about there.
They definitely whacks
him down and you know,
keep them in shape and
the moisture's in issue,
you can,
you know,
store it in a crappy place and
it can't get bounced around.
And while I was at um,
Conan with Sturgill Simpson,
Sturgill Simpson is a friend of mine,
he's a country music guy
and he was performing on the
show and they asked him if
he wanted to put his guitar out there
early so that it can acclimate to the,
the,
the temperature in that room because
they keep the room where they fill in
Coleman any five degrees,
she would chilly.
So that everybody's like,
whoa.
It gives you like a little bit
more energy as an audience.
Like if the worst thing you want is
people like really warm and really tired.
Yeah.
So you give him like a little bit of
a chill and that's like such an old,
old school,
David Letterman Trek,
right?
So they put his guitar out there early
so we can get you and then they have to
tune it again.
So you have to go out there,
you have to play with it,
you have to know where it should
be for every single note and you,
you're twisting those
little things on top.
And I'm like,
the wood itself moves and changes in
10 20 minutes and humidity of the room.
That's fucking bananas,
man.
That is so crazy to think that it's
so specialized and they can't make,
he was telling me that you can't make a
really good guitar out of anything other
than wood.
Just doesn't sound right.
They can make some electric ones.
I like plexiglass and a shit and they,
but it's a different sort of a thing.
But even then,
not as good,
like you want blood,
right?
And they're steel.
There's the ones that are all metal,
you know?
But yeah.
Now what is the one,
I don't know.
I met,
I met a good guy who made
guitars for people and he,
you know,
he looked exactly like you think he
would with ponytail and a beard and you
know,
like he's in the hall that,
and that's how they did it was
I was with John Paul Jones,
uh,
from led Zeppelin or whatever he would,
he,
he was in them crooked vultures with
Dave Grohl and I got to meet him in,
he introduces
me to this fellow and he's like,
well,
who's this guy?
And he's like,
he makes Madeline's Whoa.
And I'm like,
oh.
And he's now,
he's my friend.
I brought him along with me.
He makes guitars and mandolins
and that's what I plan.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's all he did.
And then people have like this really
intense relationship with the guy who
makes their guitar.
Yeah.
I know.
Due to Gush Acoustic guitars
from like famous makers,
they become friends
with that famous maker.
You know,
this is a,
this is how pool cue thing to pull cues,
which are also,
they can't figure out a way to make
them really good at anything other than
wood.
Yeah.
It's interesting that,
and they have relationships
with the makers.
Like guys who play with certain guys.
Karen's,
you're like,
well look,
it was really close
friendship with this guy.
I'll make sure cue.
But uh,
the um,
it's interesting to me
that like they haven't,
no one's been able to figure out in all
the years that we've been manufacturing
things,
something that's better than something
that just grows in the ground.
That's a trip that for guitars,
for pool cues,
for this table,
man,
this table feels good.
Like when I put my hand on this tape and
I feel the grain of it and I move like
this is like,
I think this table makes
a better conversation.
I really do.
I think if this,
if there was this plastic thing here
with I go like one of the formica top,
I think we'd feel less comfortable.
Now you're,
then you're in a break room.
Yeah.
Then you're not meant to stay.
You're meant to blow after 15 we,
even these bricks,
these bricks are bullshit.
Yeah.
But they're not bullshit.
They're actual bricks.
There's a slice,
they take a brick and they'd veneer.
Really?
Yeah.
And then they put it,
they put a wooden,
a metal sheet up and then they put the
SPAC all in or whatever the fuck it is.
And then they put the bricks in.
If they lay them one at a time.
Individually.
Yeah.
Like it's not like a,
like a wallpaper.
It's an actual,
their actual bricks.
But to me was like,
I know that's real.
So if I go back there and
touch that feels like,
that feels like a real organic
thing and bricks or you know what?
Mud and composite and all sorts
of shit thrown into a mold.
You still have to mold
and they're all irregular.
I would have a wooden floor if,
uh,
if I own this place I would change it.
I would turn the flu
maybe too nosy for studio.
Gives a fuck all low,
low.
Let it echo.
I would,
I would feel better.
I feel better with like shit that's like,
like organic stuff.
I agree.
Like if you could be in a grow room,
that would be the ultimate conversation.
If you could just do a podcast,
a video podcast from a grow room without
going to jail or without getting your
place stormed by people that you know.
No,
there's $1 million worth of plants there.
You're already getting me put in
jail and how your questions today.
Not True.
We live in a new day.
Like if you could go to one of those
Warren Buffet owned grow rooms in Colorado
with I five indoor acres.
They have like five indoor acre ones at
this dude I know works out and they have
two levels.
There's an upper and a lower Carlo bottles
taken shit to the next level son and
it just got back from Denver.
That is the beginning.
There's the beginning
for the whole country.
The whole country is going to become that.
The whole country is going to become just
like Colorado because they're going to
get addicted to the revenue and then
they're going to get addicted to the
behavior.
The revenue is one thing,
but you go to Colorado right now,
you have a less drunk driving accidents.
You have less violent crime.
You have the lowest incident of Duis
and something like 25 years there.
There's all sorts of like positive
benefits to what the fuck's going on here.
You're almost answering the next question,
which is why isn't it
happening everywhere?
It's like,
well,
if they're going to sell less alcohol,
then there's definitely forces that
don't want to sell and only that.
Yeah,
you've got to worry about
the criminals like the,
I know someone who has a set up
where he has blackwater type duties.
There's these dudes have bulletproof vests
and they walk around with the machine
guns and they're outside of this grow
room because they're dealing with millions
of dollars and million and the banking
laws because the banking laws are still
archaic.
They are dealing in a
cash basis in Colorado.
He pay cash money like
you do here in California.
So every dispensary's you know got way
too much money because they can't use
credit cards cause and then what did they
do when they take it to the bank banks
down except more than $10,000 yeah.
Well that's also what's going on with
these asset forfeiture laws that are also
being,
one of them got overturned.
What did we say,
Tennessee we talked about the other day.
It got overturned in Tennessee where
they were stealing people's money.
Man.
People were driving somewhere like say
if you wanted to buy a car and you had
$7,000 on you and you,
you left your house with like this
money that you save for a long time.
If they pull you over and they go,
why do you have $7,000 on new?
And you're like,
Whoa,
but her car like the fuck Outta here.
They would just take that money and then
you would have to prove somehow talked
theft is theft.
It's not only just daft,
but they would spend that money on any,
it goes into a bank vault.
They spent it in the most ironic way.
They bought a fucking
Margarita machine and they,
they,
they were using this Margarita
machine at a cop party.
So you use the drug money.
Have you thought someone
was selling drugs?
You took it and then you bought a
fucking Margarita machine with this wow.
To do,
give her,
give yourselves legal drugs.
Like you took drug money
to buy some drug machines.
It's unbelievably gross.
Careless.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's,
that's part of what they were doing in
California with the medical marijuana.
Medical marijuana is a state legal thing.
So these places we're
following all the state laws.
They got licenses to open.
They opened up,
they even went through this
whole dispute where they said,
look,
a lot of you are too close to schools.
You've got to close down.
There's always a legislation that got
passed and a lot of pot stores had to get
closed down.
Even after that,
the DEA came in,
they,
Jack booted these fucking
kids that were working there.
There's one,
there were these guys
stepping on his kid's neck.
The kid is totally being compliant.
They got 'em zip tied on the ground.
He steps on his neck
when he gets off of him.
I mean,
it's fucked up to what I
get enraged when I see that.
I want to beat the fuck out
of that guy for doing that.
Just,
it's so horrible.
And I think if that was
your son or your daughter,
some 20 year old college kid who gets
their head stepped on by some fucking
cunt,
well they would steal the money and
then they would say that the charges are
pending and never file.
So that three quarters of $1 million
that they stole from your pot place and
you're only working,
you're making 20 bucks an hour,
whatever work in there and
they're stepping on your
fucking neck and zip tying
your wrists until you have cuts on them.
You know,
for what and you don't even,
you're not even violating
a fucking federal law will.
The last,
uh,
d head of the Ge,
I just resigned.
And a god,
that woman was very bad about pot.
She was awful at this number.
Look at this number.
In 2012 Texas law enforcement
and prosecutors ended the
year with $143 million
in your honors for accounts.
143 million.
40,007 talking about this is what's
wrapped about everything that is
unbelievable.
This is the,
this one year,
the state of Texas law enforcement
preying on the people of state of stealing
from the people stealing
$143 million just in a year.
I'm sorry I interrupted
you about that DEA late 80,
late or not at all.
What's ironic is that she got put under,
you know what,
what took her down of prostitution party.
Oh yeah.
The Dea had,
they were hiring like secret service.
They had a little fun,
good service and the DEA were
having fun and another coach.
What's,
what the fuck.
Leave him alone.
She got taken down for that and she is
not very progressive and I'm hoping that
the attorney general is
blamed for handling of agents,
sex parties with hookers.
Can't they just have a
little fun off the job?
Uh,
Manny's got damn nannies as long
as they weren't using state money.
I mean we're,
where'd the money go?
Well,
with money with the DEA is not exactly
the most organized division of our
government.
What we've played that Jared was a
Jared Polis was the representative of
Colorado who is grilling her on what is
more addictive marijuana or crystal meth
was more directive that
marijuana or heroin,
what is worse for you?
I think that all drugs and he'd
just kind of asking her what is,
what is worse?
Is marijuana as bad as crystal meth?
Can you just answer that?
I think
all illegal drugs are bad and it's like
the most maddening fucking bureaucratic
red tape horseshit conversation.
Right?
That was the house he never
fess up and she should change.
Washington went legal basically from
Washington right around here looking out
the window of her office,
denying of reality that's going on
right in front of and not only that,
denying all of the medical studies that
have all been completed turned in peer
reviewed,
observed by everyone on the Internet.
It's not like a,
it's not some crazy conspiracy and it's
not like a mystery that pot's not bad
for you.
I mean,
and whatever negative effects
that they've attributed to it.
Mike,
God,
you saw that bloody diarrhea commercial.
We've already talked about this.
Not Everybody has the same reaction to
all sorts of different things in your
body,
but when it comes to like
the most mild have mild,
when you,
when you look at the worst case
scenario for reaction for pot,
God damn,
it's pretty mild.
So for fall asleep,
a few people seem to have
issues with like what they get.
They can't stop smoking pot.
Guess what?
People have issues with scratch tickets.
Okay.
If they have issues with speeding,
there's people that
can't go the speed limit.
They have a,
they do.
Do you have an addiction
to like pushing l dilemma?
Like they want to just go just a cat.
It's not even that they're in a rush.
It's just they have this weird addiction
to doing something that's naughty.
I'm just,
because I can't stop it and they'll
get 1516 fucking speeding tickets,
lose their license.
They can't slow the house.
It's not a Sammy Hagar Song.
They're real human beings,
right?
People are addicted to all kinds of shit.
That's why like a lady like that is,
is it's really dangerous,
Dan.
It was a person like
that testifying on TV.
If you don't have a guy like Jared Polis,
a guy who just grills her,
it makes her look like a
fool and doesn't do it in a,
I mean he's not being an asshole about it.
He's not being mean or he's not pointing
fingers and yelling and using hyperbole
and theater.
He shocking,
shocking use of the post though.
I mean they make you the head of the
DEA and you're supposed to be in a semi
progressive government
and who do you report to?
The president or Eric
Holder or whoever it is and,
but that's the hustle.
The hustle is that this is a
semi progressive government,
but it is no such thing.
They don't exist anymore.
You can't get in there if
you're semi progressive union,
you can't,
you can put on the semi semi progressive
tee shirt when you're running for
office.
Right.
But when they had a redact
all that shit from the,
uh,
the hope and change or whatever the fuck
his website was about whistleblowers
when people after the Edward
Snowden thing where like,
hey man,
do you remember what you said that
you were going to honor them and uh,
and they were important part of
the process and blah blah blah.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
And they just pull all that stuff.
It's all,
it's a dance.
It's a dance.
Everyone essentially who gets
into office has the same master.
They all have the same mass.
Oh no question of that.
But I think we were saying about pot,
the,
the thing people are going to
get addicted to is the money.
Yeah,
call it.
The Colorado model is so successful and
other been to Washington state too and
it's just spinning money for them.
And I said on my show last week,
they can't have a bake
sale and make this money.
There's the state that kind
of revenue is like found.
Yeah.
And I said,
Andy,
you don't have to open a casino.
You know,
it keeps that,
I mean it's just,
I dunno,
I find it a lot more acceptable and
progressive than building casinos in bars
everywhere.
Well,
you know,
when you see the ebb and the tide of,
of society and you see,
you know,
at one point in time the Republicans
were the really open minded progressive
party.
That was a long time ago.
That was what a Republican was,
what a Republican was,
was totally different
than what a Democrat was.
There was almost polar opposites.
And w another thing that you're seeing
today really lately like it seems like
over the last few years is like the
people who are progressive probably as a
reaction to all the assholery that they
had to deal with as a young person or
all the,
the all the,
what they believe is the slights and the
misappropriation of money for war and
all the different shit that they're,
they should be right about,
they should be angry about.
But now they're the aggressive ones
when it comes to policing speech.
When it comes to like shielding people
from anything that might make me
uncomfortable.
Fat Shaming.
There's a lot of,
it's crazy talk and really aggressive
about it comes from the left now.
I was like,
they're the school moms.
You know,
there's,
it means someone,
someone wrote that on Twitter.
I think Christina Summers was,
I forget the tweet.
I retweeted it the other day,
but it was so appropriate
because it was exactly that.
It's like,
how did this happen?
It's shifted.
And then Bruce Jenner goes on TV,
says he's becoming a woman
and he's a Republican.
And everybody went,
wait,
what?
Diane stores reaction was fantastic.
I cried laughing.
She went,
what?
And then she goes,
you're a republican.
And he goes,
is there anything wrong with that?
She said,
no,
no.
So you're going to go to John
Bayner and mentioned McConnell.
And he went,
yeah,
I do it in a heartbeat.
And she just went,
there was a tank of her life.
You're barking up the wrong tree,
bro.
Hames.
Well,
he's a an odd case in that unique,
obviously.
Yeah,
he's famous.
He's got a past.
He's a famous sports star.
There's a lot going on,
but I think for transgender people,
I think it's amazing.
Oh,
it's fantastic.
Two hours on TV and dedicated to this
person who's decided to become a woman.
And then here's the thing,
someone,
people will go,
oh,
well,
you know what?
What about the possibility that
what he has a mental illness,
what that is possible.
Listen,
it is possible.
This pie,
there's all sorts of possibilities
when it comes to mental illnesses,
but that wasn't my point.
My point is if he has a mental illness
in the worst case scenario of the mental
illnesses,
he wants to be a woman and
then it becomes a woman.
Right?
But he's lesbian.
That's way better than not Hetero,
which was weird.
No,
he's a,
he's going to become a lesbian who he's
gunna become a lesbian because he's a
man.
He was using he pronouns,
right.
He wanted to be referred
to as Bruce and he,
so like he has always been a woman.
So it's very,
and you know you're supposed to like,
he's supposed to not questioning that and
let people get away with anything when
it comes to he,
she gender definitions,
I guess that would be queer or whatever.
Whatever it is,
whatever the fuck he wants it to be.
The point being why?
First of all,
why do you give a shit if he
wants to remove his penis or not?
And second,
if the worst case scenario
is he becomes a woman,
is it really so bad to be a woman at
65 what fucking difference does it mean
right at 65 anybody who fucks
you is throwing you a bone,
right?
Let's be honest.
And that's like,
if you're rushing me,
I'm sitting right in here.
If you're going to become a woman,
that's a pro stop.
Show me anything.
If you want to become a woman,
that's the best time
when it's over anyway.
And we wouldn't be a 65 year
old man or a 65 year old woman.
I don't know what the fuck you dude.
Just like be a woman now.
Perfect.
And you don't even need an operation.
I thought it was a woman,
Diane Sawyer or was being pretty
good at been interviewing them.
And then when he said
he wanted to be a woman,
she's like,
you missed all the good years.
And I thought,
that's really sexist.
You're a 65 year old woman,
Diane.
Only that she's basing his
value on whether or not,
and we'll want to have any,
she all of a sudden she's
using the standard that I have.
Sure.
She wouldn't want to
be judged by if I said,
well Diane,
you're over 60 I don't find
you as attractive as I did.
You know what I mean?
Like,
and I thought that was
really a wild thing to say.
I mean I understood it because it's a
knee jerk reactionary thing to say it like
what you don't do that,
you're not going to get the budget.
You know like right.
Someone would say,
but I also thought a,
you're at New York intellectual media
chattering class rich involved person
type.
That was a pretty weird reaction.
Nigga.
You missed all the good years.
Especially since she's that age.
Yeah.
Well,
I think she has the license to
say because she's out of course.
But also it's like,
you know,
just highlights how ridiculous the
progressive structure of language has be,
but has to fall into,
he can't,
she can't make a joke like
that to him about that.
It's funny.
It's funny,
but it was so sexist.
Like I'm pretty sure
that Diet fucking story,
it's a sexist against women.
Pretty sure you know,
you can be God [inaudible] certain no,
you didn't even,
you're right.
And what you said,
and if you judge everybody
by the standards,
they're like really super progressive
complainers will judge people by it
because there are certain things that
people will write blogs about where you
go,
Jesus fucking Christ,
will you stop let off.
Will you just stop?
This is your being completely ridiculous.
Like he was one,
there was a fat shaming one that I
tweeted the other day about protein world.
This thing that's going on in England,
they have this,
uh,
this billboard is in England.
They have this billboard that says,
uh,
you know,
is your body beach body ready?
Oh yeah,
I saw that.
And there's a girl in a bikini looks
really hot and people got angry that they
were fat shaming that
by showing this girl,
so look at this,
are you beach body?
Rather than,
they took pictures of it.
Right.
And they were facing them fuck off on it
and stuff like the protein world about,
no,
actually that's not true.
What would those be?
Facings.
Most of them were photoshops.
Most of them are people bullshitting.
And guess I didn't read very carefully.
Yeah.
Well because a lot of
social justice warriors,
it would be really into doing something
like that are incredibly socially
retarded.
Yeah.
And they have a lot of,
you know,
social anxiety and they're
not going to go out.
Some of them would,
but they're not going to likely go out,
paint over this shit,
new practicing or whatever that uh,
he was a nice gap.
The Powell,
the,
the acne cream was,
isn't this also an unrealistic,
no.
Awesome body.
No,
it's not if you're that girl,
but it's genetic.
I mean,
if you're that girl,
it's not impossible,
but it is genetic.
I mean,
yeah,
but we're all,
you know,
there's always going to be the perfect
looking people and sure everyone will
always want to look like them.
And then there's the
whole question of that.
But that's not shaming.
Okay.
That is impressive.
That's inspiring.
And if there,
is it because you're attracted to you,
maybe,
but if you're a woman and you
can possibly look like that,
which is not all women.
Some women have odd shaped bodies.
I was just a fact.
We've all met women who
are boxy or really wide.
And you know,
it's probably annoying to
them to see shit like that.
But guess what?
When that fucking dude who
plays Tyrion Lannister,
what's his name?
The,
the,
the guy,
the small man.
Um,
what does this dude from game of Thrones,
Oh yeah.
What is his name?
Peter Dinklage.
When Peter Dinklage sees a
fucking Abercrombie and Fitch ad,
but the dude with a six pack,
you know,
with long legs and long arms and shit.
I bet that freaked him the fuck out too.
But doesn't mean Abercrombie and Fitch
had stopped showing twinks with six packs
to sell underwear.
It's fine.
It's like it's not body shaming.
It should pressive.
That's what it is.
It's unusual.
It's not the mean that body,
not the mean.
Who's got a body like that?
The woman's got a perfect body.
That's not normal.
That's not a lot of people blind.
She's gray.
It's not fat shaming.
Here's a real fucking problem with that.
Here's the real problem.
What they're doing,
they're selling.
They're selling like
some sort of diet plan.
That was not what it was,
right?
Isn't that what it is?
See what it is.
What?
What is it?
If it's,
is it just protein?
What's pull?
Go to the actual thing itself,
but see where few are so mad,
like look at that.
I smashed patriarchy with a hammer.
I scroll down and look at that.
Look at this.
If I had a hammer,
I'd smash patriarchy.
I found it in the hammer.
Has feminism written on the handle of,
look,
I just want to tell you that woman in
that picture is an actual woman like she
actually exists.
That's not fair enough.
It's not patriarchy because
someone wants to look like that.
She's attractive.
That is a sexually attractive woman.
It's not us,
but our dominant paradigm that
depresses us at all times.
Joe,
if you decide to look
at the world like that,
you can find absolutely everywhere you go.
That's why sometimes I think it'd be fun
to be a right wing conservative because
then you,
you can just blame lots of
people for stuff and well,
how about being a left wing radical?
No,
it's exactly the same.
I have all these people in the fray,
Dev and all these people.
But you're not so left wing radical
or this doesn't make sense to you?
Well,
most things make sense if you
think about it after awhile.
I just don't.
I think that people are absolutely would
get uncomfortable if their body could
never look like that and they
would walk by and see that.
But that's the breaks,
you know?
That's just how,
that's life.
Life hands you weird cards and if you
believe in freedom you believe that
someone should be able to
sell the image of that to
stand there with the Bikini
and use it for their products.
The prize,
like no one really product cause no
one really did to face the boards.
It was just,
no,
it's all bullshit because I thought I
sell one of those the other day they will
look some money.
Some people might have done it,
but apparently according to
the people at protein world,
they had a state,
a statement.
They said that they were
all photoshops if they,
hi Lindsay and I live in French fi world
and it's a little bit different in my
world.
You're,
you're a little,
I am beach body ready
and French fry world.
I'm material heirloom tomato
world heirloom tomato.
It's what I live off of.
Little Balsamic Vinegar,
a little sea salt sprinkled on top on it.
No,
you don't need that fucking cow shit
and just slice through that tomato.
It's one of the most
delicious things in the world.
Heirloom tomatoes with a little balsamic
vinegar and just a little dash of
Cecil.
And my wife really likes it,
so you know what I mean?
It's beautiful.
Well,
tomatoes are supposed to taste like that,
but those tomatoes last like an hour you,
you buy heirloom tomatoes
from the grocery store.
Those bitches are good for like a day
and then they start getting all mushy.
But when you eat them,
you understand that
tomatoes are really a fruit.
That difference between,
uh,
the big puffy,
watery agro farm.
The hard ones that can travel for weeks.
They can,
they bred them that way.
They bounce,
they have like,
they don't take,
they taste really bland.
Yeah.
Why don't we,
there's a big difference between
those and like the Jersey beef,
steak,
tomatoes and old,
they're old jeans and
that's genetically modified.
Like when people start talking
about genetic modifications,
guess what?
That's what that is.
That's what the tomatoes
in the corner breeding.
It's an apples.
That's why there's only like five
kinds of apples instead of a thousand.
Yeah,
right.
Oh,
and they're like,
girl is fucked too.
We like five different
kinds of potatoes here.
But in South America obviously,
where the potato was invented,
there's thousands of strains.
Yeah.
They have all the different shape and
purple and green and all weird different
operators and shit.
You ever seen Yukon?
Like how much is involved in processing
that and making food out of it?
Oh my God.
How'd he say it?
I would say Yakka.
Hmm.
You're probably right.
Yeah.
If I was called porter,
I'd write a song about that you say.
Hmm.
But you know,
it's like on one hand,
what is that?
The humble potato?
That's all the different,
oh yeah,
it's a potatoes.
Whoa.
They look really cool.
I mean,
the ink has South America
and the American Indians,
uh,
and uh,
on,
in Moscow,
in North America invented
the horticulture and uh,
the husbands or eve or
whatever you call it,
uh,
if potatoes and corn,
corn was not an edible product till the
Indian started planning it and making it
into something they could
eat and they developed it.
And the ink is an,
all the tribes that lived in South America
and those civilizations developed all
those potatoes and bread them.
That's amazing.
And so it's a,
it's an extraordinary feat of agriculture.
The end,
the fact that potatoes and corn basically
saved Europe from starvation in that
same time period.
We're talking about when they were able
to bring all that back from the new
world,
Europe wasn't doing so hot with the
nutrition right around then because they
didn't have a lot of
vegetables that captain,
uh,
potatoes like a perfect vegetable,
right?
Yeah.
You could actually live on potatoes
almost to the exclusion of everything else
and not die cause it hasn't
relied in than in it.
It's really rich in vitamin
C and potassium to d as well.
Yeah.
Data's or like this extraordinary kind of,
and then what do we do with it?
We'd take the fucking nutritious part off
of it and we boil it and then put salt
on it.
It's awesome.
It's so great.
Then put it in bleach lessons,
it ranch dressing and then,
and like a corn,
you know,
that,
that the whole argument over
Gmo corn and everything.
I was like,
yeah,
I don't know that.
And also that GMO corn,
the stuff that again,
um,
for like uh,
for cattle and stuff,
you can't even eat that shit.
Oh No.
It's like the stuff they
grow for feed for animals,
like the growth,
you know,
high in protein and resistant to
pesticides and all that stuff.
They in that show,
the documentary king corn,
they tried eating it.
You know,
they grew at an acre of corn and they
went through the whole process and through
the documentary and then they try
to eat their core and they're like,
well fuck,
are we growing?
Isn't that horrible?
Gusting it's crazy.
It's crazy.
Well that's when you find out
how dangerous California's
drought is because we
always associate the heartland
with growing our VI vegetables.
But that's not really the case.
The heartland is where
we grow all the corn.
We grow up a lot of different shit.
Obviously there's a lot of soy,
all sorts of different things get grown.
But California is responsible for like
a huge percentage of the tomatoes,
huge percentage of the almonds,
a huge percentage of the blueberries,
Avocados,
strawberries,
oranges.
There's a whole lot of shit that gets
grown in California and you find out how
fuck we are with water.
It's when you realize like,
oh,
this is a food issue for people is
not just a food issue for our food.
It's a food issue front the whole country.
That's why I want to lead a
midnight raid to lake mead tonight.
If you guys are up for it,
you gotta steal water from Nevada?
Yeah,
I got a truck.
It's pretty big.
I thought we could get
some jugs and whatnot.
Now.
I haven't thought this
plan out the whole way.
How good is this lake mead water?
Well,
it's pretty tasty.
It's gotten,
it's been run through a damn.
So there's,
you know,
filter with a big Britta.
Exactly.
I don't think there's
any impurities is in,
put it in a bong,
whatever.
Isn't it low?
Is in lake mead low as well.
I feel like that was
something that was a concern.
Oh yeah,
I would presume reservoirs.
It's terrible.
This is the worst one I remember.
I don't know if you lived in
California your whole life,
are you from company?
Oh No.
I moved here in 94 where are you from?
I grew up mostly in Boston,
Boston,
born in New Jersey.
I've lived out here from age seven
to 11 though in San Francisco.
Oh yeah.
Well we're not in the seven late seventies
there was a huge shock and that one
was the first one that I
remember really getting serious.
Yeah,
I was here for that,
I believe.
I think that was like 78 or something.
Right?
Lake mead may hit record low.
Can you believe this?
So look at the shoreline.
My God.
Yeah,
the shoreline.
The marina is going to be dirt.
Well,
that's how lake or Travis is in Austin.
I've seen that.
That's terrifying.
Lake Travis is way worse.
Pull up pictures of Lake Travis in Austin,
Texas because some folks bought these
multimillion dollar gorgeous estates on
the water of this amazing leg,
and I'm like,
honey,
we are living the fucking dream.
We have a house on the lake.
Look at this.
It's incredible.
You go out your back door,
you have a cocktail,
you hear the fucking,
the frogs,
cricket,
cricket kick,
and you're like,
we live on the lake.
This is amazing.
Well then the lake is 200 yards away now.
Right?
Right.
I've lost most of your leg.
Yeah.
Have your mode is u boats in the sand?
There's no does not.
It's not even money anymore.
Like your boat is laying out.
How come no one's ever figured
out how to seed clouds?
Dennis,
I know how to do it.
You get all that water from the fucking
glaciers at the complainant about,
Ooh,
no,
no.
You'd get a pipe.
You put it on the water.
You take the water back.
The same that I do with oil.
Look at that.
Ooh,
not insane.
These are photos.
We're looking at photos
right now of Lake Travis.
We could see people's docs like that.
See those houses up there.
But those houses were
like shoreline houses.
Like that's the water level.
There is nothing left.
Nothing left.
So these houses,
like they had this big back yard and the
backyard looked over this dock and they
would go out to their boat and
just fucking jet set lifestyle.
Look at me.
You live in Austin,
Texas,
like I fucking gangster.
And then it all went away.
The water like literally all went away.
It is the craziest thing to look at it
from a satellite photo nor from aerial
photo rather because you realize where um,
the,
the shore used to be,
there's some pretty distinct,
uh,
versus like that see that it looks
like a river that used to all be blue.
That whole thing was blue and they're
letting that motherfucker dry out because
a,
they pump water in the lake.
Austin Lake Austin is still full.
I think they get their water
from the Colorado or something.
The Missouri maybe.
What do I know?
What am I?
Lake expert.
But the point is they
get their water and they,
they still make sure that
Lake Austin gets water,
but they don't do it to Lake Travis.
And they're like,
fuck it,
we've got to pick a pick a winner.
And you ain't it.
Look at that house in the
lower right hand side.
Jamie.
Look,
these people just sitting there.
Oh my God,
that's insane.
What's left of the lake?
There was one in the
lower right hand side,
January.
You could see this big
mansion that had a backyard.
If you were before you
clicked on that one.
Yeah,
right there.
Click on that one.
Look at that.
Oh my God.
This guy used to be able to go out his
back door and just fucking him and fish
and do whatever he wanted to.
God,
it must have been amazing.
Look at that house is bad ass
house power line above his house.
Gonna kill him though.
I was eight.
He built it underneath the uh,
the tower there.
He might be a ham radio operator.
He might be one of those art bell.
My,
my wife and I,
my wife and I went and looked at house
a while ago and one in La and it was in
it,
you know,
it was it a cool neighborhood
on the east side and whatnot.
And we get there and of course no one has
shown you in the pictures on Reddit or
whatever.
Or we're not rented a zoo.
I don't know what this Ilo or whatever
the fuck goes to real estate site.
Uh,
one of those electrical towers,
like right in front of it on the street.
Fuck that.
And you're like,
that's a little close for me to look
at every day to be under Donald B.
Dot.
I don't think that's healthy.
I can't be,
I think there's like actually,
although my hair,
oh shit.
Then I'd have she here all the time.
Yeah.
It would just be,
yeah,
I'd be a young Einstein with them.
I had to try to watch TV and you
hear the sound of that thing.
It's a weird sound.
Those things.
Have you ever walked by like a real
big one of those real big towers?
Like you can actually kind of hear
the electricity when you get close.
Yeah.
That freaks me the fuck out man.
Especially people that live underneath
those because there's a couple in Burbank
where it's like that you were a,
you park your car on that street and you
just hear that home and the sizzle and
you live right underneath that.
I can't be grid.
He look out your window and you
see your lights like just glow,
a little
brake lights,
just a little glow and
dimmed out little glow.
We,
we better get those trees for every
one of our outlets so we don't have the
surge man.
Well,
what's crazy is the Tesla a long fucking
time ago when he was in that battle
with Westinghouse,
Tesla wanted to make electricity
available to everyone.
Like radio.
Yeah.
Somehow or another you'd be pulling
your electricity out of the air and he
developed some kind of a
projection method of electricity.
So instead of these towers with
wires that you could monitor how much
electricity is going back and forth
and that's how they charge you.
Instead of that,
he was just going to
make everything for free.
Just little dots.
Why he was shut down so hard of course.
But yeah,
that's is a tower of power.
I don't know what they actually called it,
but that's what it says.
That's not really what it's called.
But look at that.
Yeah.
Warden Clive Tower.
That's what it was.
That was his idea.
I mean what?
Wow.
How weird is that?
Good for you though.
That they know about the cell phone towers
to go everywhere that it looked like
palm trees and shit.
Those aren't good for you either.
Can't be.
Well I think those are not that bad
though because I think those are just
receivers.
No,
there must not be received.
What about all the phones we used in
the 90s that were this big and when you
held them up for half an hour,
your teeth started to ache.
Surely that was one good for us.
Well,
he wasn't a biology major.
You know,
Tesla was a guy who was
interested in electrics,
electronics and thinking things
through and figuring out machines.
But biologically he was pretty fucked up.
He was in love with a pigeon.
Was He really?
Yeah,
he said I didn't know
anything about his personal,
other pigeon.
Yeah.
He like had a love affair.
Like he would talk about this pigeon,
like it was a woman that he loved and
he also had some sort of a strange
relationship with a woman.
Again,
like she prefaced this by saying,
I got this from documentary.
It could be totally bullshit,
but uh,
and I haven't seen
anything about it since,
but that he wrote
something about destroying,
impose his sexuality.
Like he had been in some sort of an
affair with some woman and it was so
distracting and crazy that he
might've decided to get castrated.
Wow.
Yeah.
It'd be like a,
remember that term
destroying his sexuality.
I don't remember what the fuck the,
now I'm going to have to
read them out to me too.
God Damn it.
Oh,
I know.
Tesla and then,
uh,
Edison fought tooth and nail
and medicine beat his ass.
Basic girl.
I Westinghouse's she's saying.
Yeah.
Well he also benefited
greatly from knowing Tesla.
Didn't he want,
uh,
alternating current?
He,
he's the reason why we have all,
if you wanted direct,
current Tesla wanted alternate and
Edison had the bright idea that direct
current,
what's going to be better?
Well,
you remember he used
that fucking elephant.
They electrocuted an
elephant to prove a point.
Like Edison was such a Douche bag.
He killed an elephant on film.
Yeah.
Just so that everybody
would think that uh,
alternating current was dangerous.
How about just don't electrocute
anybody with anything direct.
Current,
alternating current.
They'd cook the shit out of that elephant.
They did it in like a
big public plates too,
which is not that long ago.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Think about that.
These days cook,
they cooked an elephant on TV in front
of everybody to for no reason other than
to show that their competitors method
of delivering electricity was inferior.
Is this the video?
Oh,
this is fucked up to watch,
man.
I have a thing about elephants,
Elephants are,
they seem to be really smart.
Topsy.
They are.
They're really sensitive.
Yeah.
They seem to be really smart and they
do have memories and they trust us.
And then,
you know,
you take this elephant and you lead it.
No,
it's just awful.
I mean,
it's one thing if you've got an elephant
that's storming through villages and
stomping the shit out of
people and killing them,
but then you've got to wonder,
well,
what the fuck makes that elephant?
So Matt,
so here they hit it with the
electricity is so fucked up,
man.
They cook the shit out of this elephant.
It's standing there and they're
just pumping it through them.
He wants to get free too.
Yeah,
it's really hardcore.
When you,
when you see it come on,
like,
here it is right there.
Bam.
You could see that he starts smoking.
Oh God.
Terrible.
It's so fucked up.
And he just falls over
completely dead and stiff.
It's so nuts.
But that was such a new thing.
6,006 years,
not volts.
Uh,
does it say no,
no,
no.
Three,
three.
Whoa.
1903,
12 years.
Wow.
Oh,
not that long.
Door over years is nothing.
That's nothing.
I wonder what they did with the alpha.
I don't want,
if they ate it and cooked it,
oh,
you know what?
I mean,
it's that Coney island,
they'd probably just slice it
open and had burgers and the,
I don't think they did anything with it.
I bet they buried it somewhere.
I don't know.
But they wouldn't even think
about eating an elephant,
which is kind of fucked up.
This is the only saving grace to those
people that hunt those elephants and
other countries is the,
the,
the villagers who are,
most of them have no meat at all.
They get to eat that elephant meat.
That's it.
Other than that,
you,
Caroline,
elephant and elephant seem to be,
they don't just seem to be smart.
They seem to be like these
like intense social creatures.
They pair up,
they,
they recognize each other after,
I hadn't seen each other in decades.
This is crazy video of this.
I think it's a mother and a
son or something like that
and they hadn't seen each
other in forever and the two elephants
each other and they run to each other and
they like,
they hadn't seen each other in decades
and they immediately recognized each
other.
They have six extraordinary
memories and they can smell water.
Wow.
That's why when they're,
when they roam far and wide during
the drought season or whatever,
they can smell it and they
can dig underneath and went,
Whoa,
that's insane.
They're highly,
and what are those?
Those,
those horn,
the tusks are for fighting.
Right.
They crash into each other and Duke it
out with those tusks to keep them for
life,
which is unusual too.
And they don't ever lose them.
They don't share that shed them.
Yeah.
Which would save a lot of fucking death
because then the elephants shed their
test.
If they did show him all the time,
people would want them every year they
would want to keep my life cause an
elephant alive would be worth way more.
And you just get the sheds.
You don't have to saw it off.
Just let them fall off.
And you could have like,
like when they have deer sheds,
like if you go to a forest,
uh,
anytime,
like near the spring when
dear start losing their,
their antlers,
you just find them and pick them up.
Yeah.
Nobody got hurt.
And you can take them and people use them.
They make jewelry with them.
And Shit and they do all kinds
of different things with them,
but it's this hard bony fucking
factory that grows in a year.
So if you see like a Mousse and they
have this enormous fucking paddle,
these paddles in the side of their head,
I mean their shoe,
they grew that,
this fee here and they're going
to grow a new one next year,
every year,
and they go in that bag.
Yup.
Wow.
Yeah,
like the size of a door.
Oh yeah.
That door to this room is not purpose.
No,
no,
they're,
they're not.
They're huge animals and they grow that
entire thing over the course of like a
month or so.
It just grows out of their
fucking head and it didn't.
Next year it'll be bigger
and next year it'll be big.
Like this Moose right here,
this is a moose.
It is a small antlers.
This is like a young Moose.
It's only like a few years old and
when they get like six and seven,
then I have these bigger and bigger and
bigger because as they get older and
they get larger and more dominant
because they continued to eat,
their horns actually get their antlers
actually get bigger so they can shell
pitch.
I been over there
fucking tired and they come at,
you know,
this huge like that's the thing that
scares off the other males like okay this
is mother.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that bizarre.
Yeah,
that's fantastic.
Elephants were like that man.
There'll be so valuable
endangered if Moose,
if Moose antlers were valuable,
the way elephant tusks were,
Moose would probably be mostly
wiped off the face of the earth,
but instead they're valued
as like a renewable resource
cause it's more valuable
to keep the Moose alive so that they
have more moose as he can eat them,
then just kill them all and
cut off their fucking atlas.
Yeah.
It's sad as shit,
man,
that seeing that,
um,
that rhino that just went extinct.
Yeah.
Essentially extinct.
I mean there's one male left and two
females and the male won't breed and now
the female is to uh,
apparently she's the one female is um,
she's too weak to accept
him on top of her.
Right.
Cause you've got to think,
yeah,
mine,
those are enormous.
So he's got to get on top of her to fuck
her and they're basically saying this
is it.
You're looking at the last three.
Yup.
These rhinos Ph night.
And I think his horn is actually
cut off so that it's not valuable.
Right.
I think there's an image
of that's the other,
there's an image like
the last remaining rhino,
right.
They cut their horns off to keep people
from poaching and key people from
poaching them.
Flip China.
Is it that wants to rhino horns.
They want it.
They don't know about Viagara over there.
They still looking for Tiger
Dick and Rhino Horn dude.
It's called Cialis.
You go to the store,
you buy it.
So what they make it over there.
It's cheaper.
Look at them.
Yes.
It's horns hacked off.
That's crazy.
Both of his horns are hacked off
unless they just wore 'em off.
Is that possible?
It is,
but I think they'd probably cut them off
because there and he's in a preserve.
Yeah.
Oh,
the [inaudible] conservancy in Kenya.
What a crazy animal that thing is though.
What do you think about all the
variation that nature has to offer?
[inaudible] difference between like a
ground squirrel and a rhinoceros and a
rhino look at that thing.
There's a famous one they brought to
Europe in the 14 hundreds and juror data
matching of it.
And it's inaccurate because
he only heard about it,
but it was a very famous painting and it
was a very famous rhino and they turned
it all around Europe and
then it finally croaked.
But everybody had to see it cause
no one had ever seen one before.
And uh,
I can't remember the name of it.
I don't know.
You'd have to look up Meti,
low rhino or yours.
Rhino.
They found rhinos in the Congo.
They found rhinos in the actual jungle
and they had only been like a legend
because they're,
they're more planes out.
It's going to say that I thought that
they'd done the belt or whatever,
but what happened was the climate
shifted around the Congo so rapidly that
plane's be camp became tropical
rain forest all around them.
Wow.
That's his sketch.
Yeah.
That's a drawing by juror.
What year is that drawing,
Janey?
Wow.
1514.
And that,
that elephant he was told about.
That's incredible.
And it toured Europe.
It was a famous elephant.
I mean rhino.
Sorry.
So he was only told about that.
It's not out anatomically accurate.
It's,
he's kind of thrown in like the feed and
the way the scales work and everything.
It's definitely a little different,
but damn.
Yeah.
Pretty fucking good.
This was like a sensation and
the early 15 hundreds in Europe,
people were like losing their shit over.
What's the other one?
The yellower one up fucked up top Jamie.
Yeah.
What does that one,
is that the original version of it?
Whoa.
I love that shit.
I love looking at like the original
version of a drawing like that.
The system that see again,
we're talking about,
uh,
his scribbles hit right in his hand.
Artist's touch his hand,
write his notes all through
the bottom and a look at that.
His handwriting and people had
elegant handwriting back then.
Look how much writing he's getting
in at the bottom of that page.
And I don't know what I'm assuming is
riding in German and the 15 hundreds.
If it's in Latin,
I can tell you he writes the name,
why Nasir Nasir on right.
That's a lot.
And it's like a transformer.
Like there's one of them.
Yeah,
that sounds good.
Drugs for riding.
Nassa Ron.
Well this area of the
Congo where the film,
these rhinos,
they had just,
they'd heard about it from
the locals and they were like,
what the fuck are they're babbling about?
There's no rhinos,
don't live in the jungle.
And then they,
uh,
they finally found him and it took a while
before they realized that the climate
has shifted and this,
these planes,
they,
the plains animals would just stuck.
Cause like almost immediately
this rain forest is,
grew around them over the course of like,
you know,
a few thousand years or
a few hundred years even.
I don't think it was very long.
I think it was actually 2000 years and
these animals get stuck there and some of
them adapted.
One of the really curious had adaptations
was this animal called a Diker.
It's like this little tiny antelope that
can now swim underwater up to a hundred
yards,
goes underwater.
Never had to do that before.
They used to just run around.
Run.
Yeah.
So now this motherfucker can swim and
the animals can adapt over time and they
eat fish.
Right?
And what are the rhinos do?
Their jungle rhinos.
They're jungle rhino.
So those,
those you're checking it antelope type.
Animal eats fish.
Yeah.
Well that's learned behavior,
right?
Well,
most likely,
but you know,
they've been finding out
lately is that deer eat birds.
Do you think they,
we didn't know about it.
Look at that.
That's a Jesus.
Whoa.
What's it eating?
The frog frog.
There's a Diker or eating a frog.
A little monster.
Hey,
don't you think of a deer?
You think they're not carnivores?
Well,
you definitely don't think it's
going to go eat a frog that day.
You got to catch a frog.
You know?
I mean,
frogs don't just let you grab them.
I know you've got to go
after that little fucker.
So I think there's,
um,
these videos,
we watched some,
one of the last podcast of a deer eating
birds and people didn't know that they
did that.
No,
you just now told him he didn't
know until like this year.
Like this is like these
to think that like,
you know these,
these birds that would die,
the ground nesting birds or
birds that fall out of trees,
that they would get eaten
by coyotes and stuff.
See all those birds coming after the deer.
It's because the deer is eating a bird
and you could see it like really clearly
as they get close to it.
The people who were filming this,
we're trying to figure out
what the fuck was going on.
And then as time went on,
they realized this deer is following
this bird around trying to bite it,
see it,
see the Berlin ground.
Yeah.
And so it's,
it's following it seats,
chasing it.
And then finally when it gets it,
it bites it and starts fucking up
this bird and it's chewing it alive.
And it's crazy to watch,
man.
I mean is it's not just
accidentally stumbling upon this.
It's going after it
cause he keeps stepping,
keep stepping the finally it gets a
hold of the bird and just starts fucking
that burn up and eating
it and apparently look,
see it.
Apparently that's what they do.
They eat birds and we have made them these
benign grass eating gentle creatures.
No,
they eat birds all alive.
And while the bird is squirming
and trying to get away,
they give zero fucks.
They have a cold hearted
bird eating demeanor.
Wow.
Who knew that about deers?
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
There's some really close up.
Oh God.
There's some close up ones.
Is a bird eating duck duck later.
Let's not birds.
Birds are.
Fuck.
We could stop anytime you want.
So let's wrap this bitch up now.
Wrap it up.
The idea is everything you need to
talk about other than the book that is
fucking amazing and I have a copy of it.
Did you sign a please?
I'm gunnery right here.
I'll send it right.
What's kittens?
What is this?
This must be for Brian.
That's my leaving shit.
I can have it if he wants it.
It's the,
it's my mascot kittens.
Mctavish you have a mascot?
Well,
kind of.
It just sort of organically
evolved over the show,
but I'll keep it.
That'll be my bookmark.
And is it a sticker?
It is.
A stub would put it on my laptop,
but a lot of times I have
to go to the airport.
I don't want any gay rumors.
You know what I'm saying?
Wow.
I'm glad that you presumed
that a kitten makes you gay.
It's not a,
it's not a giant orange cock,
but if I,
if I wanted to be less kit,
put it right there and me let me thing.
That's awesome.
See,
he likes it,
Brian.
We'll get his fucking laptop.
It's covered with pictures of himself.
Black cats on there and shit.
All sorts of stuff on there too.
I have stickers all over.
Must need more stickers.
I can't use that.
Insanity.
Janet.
Fuck.
Yeah.
And a,
where can people buy this?
Greg,
thank you for asking Mr. Joe Hogan.
They can go on.
Um,
uh,
Greg proops.com I am bitches.
Or you can,
uh,
go to,
smartest book in the world.com.
Uh,
and now you can preorder it.
It comes out on May 5th,
but you can preorder it now if you wish.
And Greg Proops,
uh,
you can see his alive podcasts.
You can actually be in the
audience for some of those fuckers,
right?
How do people get to that?
You are so right.
They can go on Greg [inaudible]
dot com I'm going to be in,
um,
uh,
see I put a heart in it too.
You said,
oh,
that's a gay rumors swirling.
I like,
um,
yeah,
I'm going to be in Brooklyn,
uh,
on the seventh,
I think may,
May 7th,
if you go onto [inaudible] dot com
or the live events on the book thing.
I'm doing a bunch of
podcasts across the country,
New York,
Chicago,
Philly,
uh,
Seattle,
Portland,
San Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
and book events as well
in all those places.
Boom.
And there you have it,
ladies and gentlemen.
Dude,
you're awesome.
Thanks.
Thanks for having me on jail.
What?
Bobby?
We should probably don't gas.
The shirts were made by this.
These are the,
these are the astronauts shirts.
If you guys know what,
what happened?
There was a,
an astronaut that got in trouble
for wearing these shirts.
Hung men of the night one.
Yeah.
We tried to balance it out,
so she sent us a gay one.
So a or a female women can wait.
I guess it would be more female than gay.
Right?
It doesn't have to be getting that.
If a woman wore that,
I would be questioning
her tastes a little bit.
What'd you for real while I'm
questioning Brian's right now,
but I understand he's just
trying to get in the spirit.
He's just being silly.
Goose man trapped in a guy's body.
Something's chapped.
The scientists got in trouble.
It was actually his friend Ellie that
made these shirts and she sent him to us,
so thank you Anil.
Their left lane.
Thank you.
A scientists dude out there.
Thanks to America.
Thanks to the world.
Okay.
I'm not a fucking Zena phobic.
I like everybody out there.
Say soon.
All right,
bye.
Awesome.
That was great.
Okay.